[Laughter]
hey everybody hey i just got you the end
of your sentence and i turned everything
off so we should be good yeah there's a
kind of a storm outside it's kind of
rumbling and stuff like i said florida
happens every day
and
if uh if the stream goes out because
that damn lightning
but we'll see we'll see i mean maybe
it'll be okay it was doing that all last
night too and i don't think we lost
power last night you know
because we were doing it was you know
what i was i was watching [ __ ] uh
gordon last night and it was storming
the whole time
thank you jeffy art thank you
for hooking us up with five dollars
right from there thank you for them
flash bulbs that's right
trying to wake me up
it was going to go to the uh
to uh to the oasis but uh i said [ __ ]
yeah say [ __ ] it i decided not to go
yeah because i was wondering about that
i was working on some [ __ ] in here and
then it was like quarter to five and i'm
like uh are you gonna go or what and
then like i started
hearing thunder yeah i was like yeah
probably a good thing
yeah it got down to around if i was
gonna go it'd be around 4 30 and i could
hear thunder by that time i was like nah
i'm not going
yeah because you don't want to go too
early because then you'd be down there
for like four or five hours and you'd be
completely hammered when you got back
yeah trying to ride back in the rain
yeah and you'd be and even if you were
on the show you'd be flailing around and
all crazy and [ __ ]
and a wipe out on the way back yeah
that's what i mean yeah you'd be all
busted up yeah
and pookie wouldn't know what to do yeah
pookie's like i remember just happened
last time no actually she didn't witness
the last time i got busted no that was
before she was born that was before she
was born yeah she's only um
five five okay
she just turned five this summer we got
her in 2017. and i think she was only
what did she do
she was only a few weeks old when we got
her her eyes were open but she was
really little look at her her eyes are
still blue though she's trying to figure
out what she's doing what she's doing
she's trying to figure out what she's
going to do next
you can't you're in the back late back
for fear
she's like you know looking down the
ground looking around like she's gonna
do okay
i can't decide on some [ __ ] i can't
decide today
it's friday
weekend's coming
oh and you guys are sitting here
drinking with us yeah warming up for the
weekend we're not going to go out this
weekend we're just going to sit here and
talk [ __ ] for a couple hours we broke
plus i have like a lot of work to do
i got a big job today i got to do a a
whole 27 slide powerpoint presentation
oh [ __ ] so
hey it's money i gotta do that tomorrow
and i gotta and i gotta do uh
do a book review video tomorrow too but
the book that i chose was like a novella
so i can probably read that in an hour
or two i have to switch it out with
see that's how i do it's like if i do
stuff ahead of time
um the scare salon video i'm putting up
tomorrow
um
if you guys there was a there was a show
in the 1960s it was called thriller that
uh boris karloff posted
and i've been wanting to watch all of
that and i thought oh i'll do like each
season as one video and then i found out
that season one had like [ __ ] 35
episodes and they're all like an hour
long and i'm like yeah okay that's not
gonna happen but um but i did
but i did do a video of the first six
episodes i did actually watch the first
six episodes and i talked about those so
that's going to go up tomorrow
thank you thank you thank you guamo
pgif yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm just glad i
just like i said i really like i enjoy
doing these shows because for me like i
guess the way
that it's kind of shaken out like the
way that i do the videos and stuff like
that it seems like the beginning of the
week like sunday monday tuesday
wednesday is like
really really like
packed with stuff like you know what i
mean like i got to do this video in that
video and that's not going to do
research for that research for that
research and we do all these movie
reviews and stuff but then like usually
by the time thursday friday roll around
mostly i've got all the stuff for the
week done so it's like
you know it's it's a lot less stressful
so i do actually really like doing these
because yeah they're relaxing yeah
they're just relaxing i wish to hang out
and have a drink and blah blah blah i
want one of the ideas that i had i wish
we could do it it doesn't work out we
tried is to have a soundtrack going in
the back like some [ __ ] relaxing
vaporwave or something but the problem
is is that a lot of it's copyrighted so
you get copyright strikes you can't ever
you can't really trust it
yeah i mean even if you go on i mean you
can go on pixabay and they have uh
ostensibly like a whole bunch of music
and stuff on there that you can use for
free but
like i said i wouldn't risk it because
you know that could be copyrighted that
somebody just like downloaded and then
uploaded on that site it's like yeah
totally use it and then the person that
actually wrote it is like no
but it's always good it would be it's
always kind of good i've seen some
streams that had like mood music going
in the background yeah that's kind of
good but you can only do that if you
don't have a specific topic
so it'd be good for a show like this but
we
haven't been able to figure anything out
i mean i could do it i could just put i
mean it'd be easy to like uh load it
into obs i can do that yeah and then in
the background just have it running kind
of low
that way you know they're at their place
[ __ ] chilling and drinking and you
have like a little bit of a background
music for it yeah i always thought it
would be good i mean look into it
maybe there's some music that's approved
by google you know because remember they
were using that [ __ ] for the [ __ ]
dead mall videos
[ __ ] that came off of google well like
they said
one of the sites that i use which is
pixabay um they have like video clips
and music and sound effects and stuff
like that that you're ostensibly allowed
to use without
you know without any copyright or
without even attributing anything and
just some music in the background yeah
for all i care about it's just there's a
lot of it on there so you have to really
kind of like dig through the [ __ ] they
they have it like um they have it
categorized by mood yeah you know it's
like do you want something like cute and
fun or do you want something kind of
like dark and chill or do you want to
you know what i mean it's kind of like
that
i made carnitas last night man those
[ __ ] are good that came out really
good yeah i'm mexican now you're mexican
now hell yeah
yeah yeah caught of ozlon said i was
mexican
he gave me a badge and everything
an actual mexican said you remember yeah
he saw me make those [ __ ] corn
tortillas
i got the tortilla press and everything
making him out of my second and he's
like you're gonna get the blue masaka
too so that's good too but i showed him
when i was doing making making them
tortillas oh you make to make tortillas
now you're mexican and i said i guess i
am
guess i am mexican well
he he shared with me uh this uh channel
it's on youtube i'm gonna plug it
it's called cooking concluding okay it's
this little cute little mexican chick
who's a [ __ ] great cook and she'll
sit there and she'll give you all her
recipes and i was using her recipes for
carnitas and i did it the same way
carnitas in uh an instant pot
you could so use like an instant pot
you take you take something like a big
piece of pork i use uh pork butt
and you slice okay you said that pork
butt yeah pork butt
slice it
emphasis and into big chunks
and you put it back you put it on on
saute put some put some uh
oil in the bottom of it
and you sear the outside all those
pieces you know and you're transferring
them in and out of there and putting
them in a big old mixing bowl to cool a
little bit because you can't fit them
all in there at once inside and and sear
the outside of it once it's seared put
it all in there
used a blend of
well it was garlic
fresh garlic um rosemary
thyme
basil basil uh bay leaves i ground that
up in it
uh cilantro
and um
what was the other one
i don't think it was a regular i forgot
what the other one was
and then a little bit of lime juice
and then orange juice
and you blend that up you put that in
there with the meat and then you put it
the equivalent of a whole a whole bottle
of coca-cola in it and pressure cook it
45 minutes and let it sit in there and
then when it comes out take it all out
of this the drippings are [ __ ] great
all right
take them take all those pieces of meat
out of the drippings
put them in a cast iron skillet and put
it in a broiler and broil each side
turning it so it's nice and crisp on the
outside kind of candified or you can
define the outside of it you'll see the
caramelized
kind of caramelize it on the outside of
it
and you'll have
big old blocks of meat that'll just
tender just it'll just come apart and
they're seared on the outside and brown
so they have crispy edges on them you
have that and it opens up and just
steams
in there and then you'll also have the
pot of those drippings
when you and what you're doing is is
you're
taking it toward
take a little bit of those drippings and
put it on a on your griddle because if
you want a big cast iron griddle put it
on there because it'll have oil in it
let it burn off a little bit throw those
tortillas on there and let them kind of
steam and flip them over to the other
side put cheese put the meat on it and
then you can take another ladle and put
some more of that liquid on there and
it'll steam it'll be crispy in some
areas and with in like gravy in the
other areas and you just top it's just
meat and cheese and then fresh
vegetables if you want you know like
some onions or tomatoes or whatever
and then you kind of sauce you want on
their salsa they're good they're [ __ ]
fantastic i ate them today today and
yesterday
but yeah they came out really really
good but you go on cooking concluding
on youtube
and go check out her
instant pot
carnitas that's the meat you use for
tacos
and it's not hot or spicy or anything
it's just salgadoo it's just savory
that's why i liked it like that because
you could actually like taste like it
was spiced but you could taste the meat
more than i mean and i'm not saying that
i don't like like spicy meat sometimes
but yeah it's just a different way yeah
it's like it doesn't have uh you know
cayenne or chili
powder or anything like that you can add
that onto the top
you want but it's just good i just liked
it because it just tasted like real real
savory meat like you said yeah you can
use that meat for anything
that's another thing too you can make
sandwich with that yeah burrito with
that yeah
so we just had like little yeah uh
yeah so where was it said oh like real
mexican tacos are small yeah that's how
you make yeah yeah you make them like
that yeah that's what i had for lunch
like just two small ones with a little
bit of meat a little bit of cheese
a couple of tomatoes a couple little
cherry tomatoes and little cherry
tomatoes yeah and uh
was there any guacamole
avocado that's right there's avocado
sauce that's right
yeah that's right i think it was ortega
brand
i think i don't remember what it is it's
a mexican bread
yeah they were uh yeah john smith said i
went to taco bell once i'm now mexican
too yeah
they're they're asking if we've seen
nope yet i still haven't it's like i
really really want to see it um
everybody's saying it's uh somebody said
it's like tremors in the best possible
way yeah which uh yeah that sounds
really boring out there yeah i know yeah
that's okay okay it's not i don't see
any lightning it's just raining really
hard
i know it probably will
but no it's just it reminded me when you
were talking about the thing i've been
watching because you guys know i love
gordon ramsay right so and he has a
million shows and i don't really know
how he has time to do them all but
whatever
so he has the new season of masterchef
which i think is season 12 i want to say
it's called back to win
and they had like some of the people
that lost like from some of the other
seasons like they asked them all back
and they're like re-competing
so i've been watching that um i guess
it's still airing because i watch it on
hulu but you can't actually watch the
new episodes until like wednesday like
three in the morning or something
because it's like a few hours after it
actually airs so they put like two new
episodes up a week
at like three in the morning and the one
one of the ones that i watched last
night and this fascinated me and i kind
of wanted to know like what you would
have done in this situation
was that you know how they have a
challenge on each show
and the challenge that they had was they
had to take
gas station snacks like just snacks you
could get in a gas station
um and they had to use at least three of
them they could use whatever else they
wanted too but they had to use at least
three of them and you had to make like a
gourmet
dish right
and so gordon did one first and he had
some kind he had like snapper or
something like that and he um
he like coated it in like crunched up
like pretzels and potato chips and [ __ ]
like that and then like i can't even
remember what else he did and it looked
really good and all that
but one guy
made
uh he made some kind of fish or chicken
or something like that that was crusted
too but then he made this sauce to go
with it and he legit melted
gummy bears
and mixed it with beer and made a sauce
out of that and like i'm watching him
make it going that is going to be the
most disgusting thing ever and like even
all the cooks were just kind of like
yeah no that's not going to work out and
then like when they tried the dish they
picked his as the best one that was like
that is weirdly delicious and i'm like i
just can't see how that could have
worked out
i don't know what kind of beer it was i
guess they had like you could use beer
and soda and stuff like that because
some people actually did use soda like
you said like for the application of you
know using like for the meat and
everything but i kind of feel like i was
kind of disappointed i wanted to see a
little bit more creativity like the
weirdest thing was the gummy bear and
beer sauce most people just kind of
copied what gordon did and they're like
oh i'm just gonna crunch up like some
pretzels and potato chips and like coat
some meat and that i'm like well
obviously that's gonna be okay because
that's something that people do anyways
when i did those carnitas i didn't have
coca-cola so you know what i used
diary publix publix diet room diet
repair
because i knew that i knew the down
pressure cooker
just basically destroys everything
anyway it's just for the carbonation
they're
the carbonated water
into pressure cooker
and it does have a little bit of
caramel coloring and a little bit of
sweetener even though it it wasn't sugar
saccharine but it worked
but it it's all just broken down in the
damn pressure cooker anyway just it's
just it's just a
soften the meat helps off the meat
tenderize it i know it's like i i feel
like people aren't as weirded out by it
nowadays because a lot of people use
coca-cola like in their pressure cooker
like to make meat with but it's like
even back in the 70s and 80s i feel like
we made cakes and stuff with soda like
seven and up yeah and stuff like that so
it's not that weird yeah the flavor of
it doesn't really matter any of them
would work they just think it's mostly
just the carbonated water the carbonated
water and i think maybe a little bit the
sugar i'm not really sure but yeah
depends on what your spice profile is
you're probably not going to taste that
anyway
yeah that's all i'm saying because it's
all just destroyed in the [ __ ]
pressure cooking process
the molecules are breaking down you know
camp guy says bowen got sent home last
night yeah spoiler alert um who's boy
bowen they on front on the master chef
oh okay yeah it's like he seemed like a
nice dude and everything and i i admire
that um that he kind of went out there
with the stuff but they said it tasted
like really bizarre and it wasn't really
any good and then i think like one of
the other chicks that got sent home she
tried to make something with
uh like fruit like fruity pebbles or
something like that like i don't think
they said fruity pebbles because maybe
they can't use that for copyright but
they said like oh fruit cereal and she
like made some kind of sauce with it and
they said that was like the weirdest
[ __ ] ever so but i was just i liked that
challenge because i'm always really into
seeing
like the creative ways that people come
up with to use it so i was kind of
disappointed like i said that everybody
just did kind of boring [ __ ] with it
other than the gummy bear and bigger
thing which i totally didn't think was
gonna work but it totally did apparently
but
just goes to show i guess that guy is
like
he knows what he's doing yeah grantham
said beer and gummy bear reduction
that's what i said
and even they said and i'm not even like
a cook or anything like that but
even like gordon and joe and that other
guy on there they're just kind of like
no that sounds like totally gross but
when they ate it they're like oh my god
that's amazing how the [ __ ] did that
work um
john says that i recently brought bought
an air fryer i feel like i've joined a
cult yeah i feel like the instant pot
the big one or the instant pot is kind
of like that too like because everybody
was getting instant pot and then like
everybody's getting an air fryer but the
reason that everybody's getting them
yeah it's trendy and stuff like that but
they're really good and they and they
work really good they're efficient
that's what i mean and especially like
the instant pot and stuff like that like
you can cook like a lot of [ __ ] in there
and it's like really really easy so i
can see why everybody recipes for it
right
it's just an easy to use pressure cooker
you feel more safe about it because
it's computer it's computer uh
monitored so if there's any kind of
problem it'll shut itself off so you're
not really afraid of blowing yourself up
i was
slightly afraid of people i was
like back in the back in the 70s there's
a possibility something could go wrong
and the [ __ ] goes off like a bomb i
mean people made bombs out of those for
a reason yeah and if the pressure can't
be released it'll eventually just blow
up like a bomb yep
literally i mean you could just blow
this side of a house out you can make a
bomb with it yeah the old ones because
they didn't really have
uh a fail-safe like nowadays like you
said everything's computerized so
there's a lot of things like to prevent
that from happening so it turns the
flipping heat off so it turns everything
off it starts [ __ ] releasing pressure
somehow there's ways where it can
release pressure right
and um
and i think there's pressure release
stuff where if the pressure gets real
high it'll mechanically blow a piece of
it out
there so
so it'll just go
you know and keep from blowing up like a
damn bomb yeah
but um yeah i was always really nervous
when my grandmother was using the
pressure cooker back in the old days
the airfryer that we got we got from uh
sam's it was only a hundred dollars
and it was it's a power xl
and it's the size of a microwave oven
and it's got little small microwave oven
it's got racks in there and you can
change all the different racks and
baskets
and it's the um
the uh
the grill
function it came with a damn non-stick
grill plate you put it on the bottom you
change that grill function it's
fantastic you could put
four
large
uh hamburger frozen hamburger patties on
there turn it up to grill [ __ ] um
put it up a [ __ ] 400 425
and you only have to flip them once and
they come out perfect yeah and uh it's
amazing yeah
air fried fried chicken in there
that is also good yeah you gotta know
how to do it though he makes pizza in
there yeah it makes real good pizza and
it's better than having to like sit
around with the with the oven up at 5 25
for hours and hours especially in the
summer time because it makes the whole
house hot yeah what you do is you take
you make the pizza in the wire baskets
you make your dough lay it out pick it
up throw it in the wire basket shape it
to that square
put all the toppings in there and you
put it in there full blast on pizza
setting
it only takes 10 uh 12 minutes when it
comes out that crust is [ __ ] perfect
it's absolutely perfect yeah perfect
yeah
and uh even if it's new dough yeah
doesn't i've noticed that you don't even
really have to age it yeah and it's best
with bread flour but i i am working with
some of the recipes that involve
all-purpose flour which is not quite as
good it's never as good but
even some of the all-purpose flour
recipes are coming close to kind of
kind of the
the dough you get to say like pizza hut
kind of like that but um which is okay
that you know you're not spending much
on that pizza it doesn't cost much to
make so
that's pizza that little pizza you made
for me though did you make that in the
airfryer the one that was on the naan
no no that was yeah yeah air fryer but
on non that's what that's what i just
said i said did you make it an air fryer
yeah yeah he made it like he just had a
piece of naan and you put you didn't put
sauce on it because like i said i like
pizza sauce but it gives me heartburn a
lot yes i did so um it was just um so he
just did cheese eggplant yeah a little
pesto cheese eggplant
mushrooms and tomatoes and that [ __ ] was
delicious
thin sliced eggplant came out of the
garden it's good on pizza it was i
wasn't sure it was really good all right
i put it on the pizza i put two of them
in there at once they weren't even on
the pizza settings i had just had two of
them in there at once
put them in there for about 12 minutes
full blast heat
and they were probably done in more like
10 minutes i was watching them but it's
just a piece of naan
non-bread indian naan bread it worked
fine
yeah that makes good like quick pizza
crust if you're too lazy to like do a
lot better
a lot better than frozen pizza a lot
better it is
yeah you know what else works is it a
flour tortilla yeah that works too it
works too i mean if you like thin crust
we've done we've done that before too
yeah
slasher fred said do you guys remember
those old domino's pizza commercials
with the noid yeah i remember those
actually where i used to work i used to
work like for this weekly like penny
saver type newspaper
and uh for whatever reason somebody had
like a big sticker of the noid like in
the dumb waiter so like every time you
opened it it was like the noid would be
i don't know why and that was like many
years after like the noid had been a
thing so i think i was probably the only
person that remembered what that was
what's up whitney
yeah tombstones are the [ __ ] yeah i
haven't had frozen pizzas in a long time
i used to get them sometimes like when i
i didn't get them usually like when i
lived alone i didn't buy them because
they were too
bit like i couldn't eat the whole thing
so i didn't like bother with it but a
long time ago like when uh when i was
married i we used to get them every now
and then
i don't like tombstone are good i used
to like digiorno to be honest i like
that kind i liked the digiorno like
rising crust yeah i thought those were
pretty good but it's been like a while
since i've had one it's all good for
people people that don't know how to
deal with dough
you know or
lazy yeah if it's just fast you know i
mean but um because i was like i i was
working all the time so i didn't really
have time to do all that yeah you want
to have
a pizza stone for your oven and you have
to [ __ ] have enough and they can get
up to you to get to at least 500 degrees
you got to heat that
stone up for an hour before you put it
on there
the digiorno pizza on there is okay
but if you're gonna go through all that
problem just learn to learn how to make
your own dough get you a pizza peel and
some corn meal and learn how to [ __ ]
get a pizza on and off
on and off of a peel and get it onto
that stone it's hard to go wrong
especially if you can get high gluten
bread flour
man
that's it's good it makes a perfect
[ __ ] dough
perfect crust
especially if you age it for time over
time like a day
or two anyway i'm going to get off the
pizza thing i'm going to get fat just
talking
no you want a diet on a diet on a diet
so we can't although we probably should
eat after the show because i'll probably
be hungry yeah i got stuff we can eat i
think all all i've had today was those
two little bitty tacos yeah this morning
i had one packet of oatmeal
and a cup of coffee
so that's it
and i can you know so maybe i can have
some a little bit of something later
yeah we can do it
okay um i have for those of you who
don't know
i'm gonna uh plug my new channel
i got a channel on twitch
if you don't have twitch you can get the
twitch app
and i'm my name on there is
tom 13 o'clock all lower case there's no
apostrophe tom 13 o'clock
and you you can follow there and
i will be playing video games and
talking to the crowd
did you stream today didn't stream today
yeah i was gonna say it i didn't hear
anything today i might stream tomorrow
but i can you know i'll uh have my um
tablet next to me so whatever you guys
say i can
i can answer and i'll be probably
playing uh
tomb raider
legend which is uh
back when laura croft was pretty
i don't know which is it's a video game
character she looks like a little
supermodel running around what does it
matter what she looked like
yeah
sorry i saw something up here that i
wanted to
that i wanted to say oh camp guy is
saying
baked pineapple one can pineapple chunks
a half a cup of all-purpose flour one
cup sugar mix in baking dish top with
one sleeve crushed ritz crackers mixed
with one stick melted butter baked 35
minutes at 350. i kind of feel like
that's
that sounds a little bit too like
remember how they always would make mock
apple pie yeah like you make it with
ritz crackers and like a couple of other
things like cream of tartar and
something like that and it tastes legit
just like an apple pie even though
there's no apples in it i haven't had it
it's crazy
i mean it's the weirdest like alchemy
that you've ever it's super weird
seriously if you ever and it's all over
the internet just say put mock apple pie
there's no apples in it but it tastes
like there is and i don't know how it
works because none of the ingredients
would suggest that would be really bad
for you that it would taste like apples
well no i'm just it was just um the
recipe came from
i think it was like yeah from like the
depression when people couldn't get
fresh fruit yeah and so they just made
it with ritz crackers and for some
reason it tasted just like [ __ ]
apples and i don't really know how it
works but okay
yeah i don't recommend it people very
high in carbohydrate if you make it
[ __ ] just make it as a gag
that'd be very bad for you i was just
sitting around eating a box of rich
crackers yeah but you're not watching it
you're not eating it every day though i
mean you could just like make it for no
nutrition in that
that's what i mean though but but like i
said you can't worry about like every
single thing you eat it's just like i do
well yeah but you're no fun though yeah
i sit there and try to calculate is that
worth eating but you're no fun though
yeah but that's the thing it's like
every now and then
yeah you know
it's nice to just like have a treat
without worrying about
about it you know what i mean that's
what i'm saying not really well that's
you though nobody else is like you so
john smith said some years ago i worked
at a hipster's [ __ ] pizza stall at
various festivals a surprising hit was
strawberry pizza
now
uh he's talking about with the
strawberry uh okay now is this a savory
pizza or is it like a dessert
pizzas what are you talking about oh
okay well i can see how this cc's i
could see how that would work it's just
pie filling
that's what i'm saying well yeah that
would be good because it just was chased
like a strawberry pie yeah or a
blueberry pie or a lemon you could they
had a or apple i mean it's just crushed
it's just on a crust and then they had
like this weird crumble that would kind
of it was kind of a you know i think
what i think it was was coffee creamer
pour it on top of it and then you bake
it and it kind of melts together to make
it yeah probably a creamy crunchy crust
on top of it it's probably probably
coffee creamer and water or something
or maybe it's just spread it just coffee
creamer sprinkled on it and baked
that'd probably do it i mean i could
it's not bad it would probably taste
like a pop-tart yeah like a pop-tart pie
yeah which yeah pop-tart
and man i love strawberry pop-tarts so
i i can't see how that would be bad that
yeah that would probably be like a fresh
strawberry pop-tart yeah
yeah that's what it tasted like every
now and then it's really funny
every now and then i get a craving for a
strawberry pop-tart right i got some i
know you do yeah i got blueberry too i
don't like the blueberry ones honestly i
don't really like most of the flavors um
the the strawberry ones with the
colorful sprinkles on top those are my
favorites and the cinnamon ones are good
too but the other ones can suck a dick i
don't really like any of the other ones
um chocolate ones are okay but um it's
not my favorite hugo jack's gonna fall
if i'm gonna play halo um i can play
halo i like halo i like halo one the old
halo
the campaign on it was pretty good
i think i played halo 2 but it's been a
while
but i i actually liked halo 1 probably
needs an update now i don't know what
that looks like now
but yeah that was a fun game when that
came out
there's something about
i liked uh late
90s
and early 2000s games where they they
had kind of there was a certain amount
of realism but they weren't really ultra
realistic yet i liked that era there's
something kind of more artistic about
the games um
like i you're not [ __ ] i'm a huge
[ __ ]
um
a double07 goldeneye fan but you can't
get it for xbox one the licensing is all
[ __ ] up on it
which is a shame you can get you can get
uh perfect dark though which is a clone
it's the same engine it's just different
different skins on it really
i have it maybe i'll play that
what i was gonna say about pop tarts
though was that i kind of get a craving
for him every now and then
but
every now and then like i like i would
be at work and like sometimes they'd
have like the little two packs you know
the little two-pack foil thing in the
snack machine
and i'd be like man why not i haven't
had one in a few months so i go and get
one and then i have one and it's really
really good but then i find that i can't
eat both of them without wanting to
throw up i don't really know i wish they
would kind of package them just like
individually instead of two because two
i feel like that's too many i always
like it kind of makes me feel sick like
if i eat two of them slasher fred said i
remember the tombstone pizza commercial
i remember this too actually with the
prisoner about to be put to death and
the executioner asking what do you want
on her tombstone i used to think that
was one of the most brilliant commercial
because you know i have a dark sense of
humor and i liked that the company went
there i said you know what they probably
named that company tombstone just so
they could do that in the commercials
and i respect that game i do
so i yeah so i really did like that
commercial that that whole thing
actually
uh strawberry the best where i'm
assuming we're talking about pop-tarts
uh s'mores pop-tarts and the iced
cinnamon are the best i don't think i've
ever had a s'mores one i'm not a big
marshmallow fan yeah i had the cinnamon
ones i really didn't know the cinnamon
ones are pretty good i i like the fruit
stuff i don't know i don't like well i
like the strawberry ones and the cherry
ones are they have cherry ones right
yeah i think so the cherry ones are
passable i don't like the strawberry
ones are my favorite
but
and i'll eat a cinnamon
i'll eat a chocolate one if i have to
yeah but other than that i mean they
might have a bunch more
flavors now that i'm not aware of
because i don't usually buy them like i
said like last time you went to sam's
you bought some but
yeah got understandable i got they had a
whole damn case of them yeah
yeah like i said you can have the
blueberry ones because i don't i don't
like it price was right honestly
the case had four packs in it
yeah i mean yes four boxes so we got pop
tarts out
i think
yeah i think each box had either eight
or twelve in it i don't remember good
thing for me that i'm too lazy to walk
down eight or twelve packs
or two in each little pack
granthar says what food sources exist in
your backyard for you to kill and eat
when the grid goes down
the neighbors the neighbors
deer
no
oh man look they got all these people
you know they think oh man i can this is
even this is even in mississippi you
know and [ __ ]
alabama and the areas where there's a
lot of deer
you hear people that have that hunt deer
you know part-time or whatever it's a
whole man we go down i got my 270. i can
get deer out there all day long yeah you
and [ __ ] millions of other people
um those deer will all be gone in a
starvation area in a few in a few months
that's what the fish and wildlife is all
about
stopping people from hunting those
things to extinction
because that last depression here in the
united states that's almost what
happened fish and wildlife at the state
level and the federal feds backed it
they did everything they could to keep
the number of hunters down to a minimum
because they would and to make sure that
all the seasons were done right so the
so the breeding of these animals wasn't
being impeded on by the hunting
pot you know the the hunting activity
the u.s population is too high
if they tried to
live as hunter-gatherers they'd eat this
place up in a [ __ ] matter of few
months
so no you can't hunt and survive
no it'd all be gone soon
this is all being held together
artificially
power production has to remain exactly
the same if it dips it's going to [ __ ]
up the crops
and when as soon as those crops are
[ __ ] up the population will start
declining
government can't feed you they don't
make anything they don't have [ __ ]
stockpiles of food
that's why i'm [ __ ] worried man
they're talking about we're going to
shut down this you know shut down
[ __ ] oil production shut down
fertilizer production and this and that
just getting rid of fertilizer alone
just that would probably [ __ ] reduce
yearly crop yields in some in certain
areas by half which would mean famine
if famine happens this place is going to
blow
these people aren't used to [ __ ]
famine and not having instant
gratification for food and
it's agribusiness you know agribusiness
supports this population without that
it'll implode
and uh
it'll be bad
and and the thing is is that the
government no matter how much power or
money they they can pull out of thin air
they can't speed the harvest
there won't be any food
and it takes years to get the harvest
right again maybe two three years and
you can't do that in a time of civil war
the same thing is happening on the
[ __ ] african continent
they're trying to they're trying to grow
food
but they're fighting during the growing
and they're attacking food production
because they're starving all at the same
time it's a vicious cycle and it never
comes back
the population then declines down to
next to nothing the area is now vacated
somebody else comes or you know somebody
else comes in there and starts from
scratch and it takes another 10 years or
a decade for that area to come back
you know and um they keep [ __ ] around
with power production
and and crops you have you'll have that
situation in europe and in the united
states and it's not going to be
recoverable recoverable i don't think
civilization is
the fragile balance of supply and demand
with an angry uncivilized population
especially
in high density uh populations in cities
they don't understand
if that atm card doesn't work or if the
ebd cards don't work and if there's
nothing in the [ __ ]
um uh
supermarkets
they're nine meals away from anarchy and
it wouldn't recover be like katrina
imagine you'd have and i lived through
katrina you'd have a katrina in every
major city simultaneously it'd be out of
control it would never recover
you'd be reforced to cannibalism
which has happened in many times in the
20th century
russia was resort resorted to
cannibalism several times
rebecca says bloody work calls out of
the blue [ __ ] my life i'll get back to
seeing a whole live show again one day
bye y'all oh that's too bad yeah you can
watch the whole thing later it'll be
fine
it'll be fine uh tammy says just had
three bucks in our backyard this morning
our puppy just sat looking at them yeah
yeah there's a lot of deer right here a
lot of bears out here
probably bunnies all that kind of stuff
i don't know i'm not really all that
worried about it
what
nothing i'm just i'm not i'm trying to
worry about anything really i try to
only worry about [ __ ] i can control
i i'm worried about that enough yeah i'm
not worried about [ __ ] i can't control
if i starve to death i starve to death
i'm really not all that worried about it
nothing's changed human beings have
always been the same and uh
feminine disease war
we're not immune
well like i said i'm not worried
not worried about it it's friday night
trying to have a good time
trying to have a good time yep
tammy also says we have two apple trees
uh they're loving right now even have a
bear that comes once in a while
oh coming to eat the apples
so did we put those you put that banana
trees in the back right
i got two banana trees the two banana
trees yeah none of that stuff will be
ready this year that will take a long
time i mean i don't like bananas
here's another thing
what i got growing back there
is all experimental i'm trying to figure
out what yields the best and what yields
the most food for the least amount of
money so far it's been eggplant eggplant
[ __ ] kicks out i mean we have like so
much eggplant eggplant
with all of it and i mean i like
eggplant i'm not saying that but i'm
being encouraged to plant more eggplant
because i know that that yields another
one that did pretty good was um
sweet potatoes
small amount of sweet potatoes in bags
yielded sweet potatoes i haven't even
eaten them and the sweet potato can stay
at room temperature up on the counter as
long as you don't wash it with water
just leave them sitting
open
in a big old [ __ ]
thing you stay for months without them
going bad they kind of get sweeter as
they get older
so sweet potatoes did well so i'm going
to do more of those some do more sweet
potatoes more
more eggplant um tomatoes kick dash for
a while but they kind of come in cycles
probably won't get eggs
any more tomatoes for another
couple months
but tomatoes do well in the south
probably do more tomatoes
bell peppers did well
got a lot of bell peppers and i uh i got
like seven or eight of them down there
that we need to eat i was gonna use them
as pizza toppings or something that's
okay or maybe like a they're big enough
to make a stuffed uh bell peppers with
oh [ __ ] i've had that in a long time
that's really good actually the thing is
and a jalapenos [ __ ] kicked ass they
made a lot here's the problem with
peppers
they don't have much many calories so
it's not something you can live off on
but you can save money they they have
flavor
you know what i mean it's it's like a
free bonus well yeah i mean no one's
trying to like live off of peppers no
you can't live off of but you have and
then i'm doing
herbs oh
i got
rosemary growing out there
basil
you got this plant out there that i'm
growing i've got what it's called it
makes these little leaves that are sweet
you can put them in coffee and crush
them and it'll act as a sweetener i
forgot the shit's called not stevia
stevia
i got a stevia out there
it's growing okay
it's not really ready to harvest i don't
really know what it's going to be like
stevia that's what i got
yeah that's what they make a lot of the
uh yeah kind of sweeteners that they
yeah i gotta
see how that yields oh
thank you thank you thank you next
dimension media love the t-shirt jenny
thank you i used to have the creep show
comic book they put out when the movie
was released i lost it though in one of
my moves i actually saw that
when i bought this t-shirt because i
bought it at fye
at the mall
and they um you know the altmo mall
that's near us and they actually had
like a little table with a bunch of
horror stuff on it and they had like
you know uh reproductions of that creep
show uh book that came out at the time
and i was actually gonna buy it but it
was like 30 dollars 35 and i was like
okay that's a little rich for my blood
but this shirt i think was 25 or 20.
like i got a couple because they were
buy one get one free or something buy
one get one half off whatever they were
so i got like this one and i got like a
halloween one too
i got a i got a lemon tree out there
it's about six seven feet tall it's
still in the it's still in the uh the
planter
i can't bury it until the summer's over
but it's got a [ __ ] ton of lemons on it
but they're all green
i think one of them turned yellow
but we'll see what that is i got two um
banana trees i put in the ground
but that'll be a couple years before i
see anything there and those those
banana trees actually make bananas the
other ones i had were decorative banana
trees i didn't even know
and then uh
got two papaya trees and i got a [ __ ]
passion fruit
um that's
i think there's a couple different kinds
of tomatoes the beef steak tomatoes
yielded the best the little cherry
tomatoes yield a lot
but towards the end of the yield the
they kind of start to lack flavor they
don't really get that big and they kind
of stay half green on one side they kind
of get sickly looking we'll see if the
if they
they should yield again
we'll see we'll see
can we just say that i'm just like so
[ __ ] glad that
august is almost over yeah even though
in florida it's still going to be hot
for like another three or four months
but that hot though but yeah but the
thing about it is that i'm always kind
of like excited whenever august is over
and i'm like september comes because i'm
like oh now it's like unofficially fall
i'm like even though it's still going to
be hot as [ __ ] for like another few
months but at least
at least we're going in the right
direction yeah it's not really hot
it it it's in the 80s
it's right now it's raining and it's 87.
yeah it says on my thing after
um after august it's still in the 80s
but the the humidity goes down i've
noticed it's not it does and it slightly
cools off at night yeah
and the wind blows a little bit better
it
blows a little bit more so it's
effectively the heat index goes down so
it doesn't feel as hot yeah i mean it's
still hot but it's not it doesn't feel
anywhere near as hot as it heats up but
it's not like you're walking outside and
like walking into a sauna and thinking
you're going to die or not yeah yeah
it's not that bad
so i don't know i think it was that bad
this year
well that's because we didn't go outside
for like days and days at a time but
most people do that
well i've always done that like i said i
was born in florida yeah so
and you knew that once once uh you know
may and june came along it's like well
i'm hibernating in front of the air
conditioning yeah you don't see it in
four months you just don't go out during
the day if you don't have to nighttime
is it cools off some it's not that bad
it's muggy but it's it's not
as punishing you know
yeah but you know it's always just kind
of like i don't know i was thinking
about that the other day i was just kind
of like oh it's like well not only
because september is like my one of my
favorite months because like my birthday
is in september too but
i just i like the whole i don't like
spring i don't like summer i don't like
any anything anything having to do with
spring or summer i don't like any of the
iconography about it i don't like any of
the kind of i don't like any of that and
maybe like people that live in like a
really cold climate they're just like
happy to see spring coming and stuff
[ __ ] that i don't like it um
i always i always get really happy
when i start saying back to school [ __ ]
and
fall stuff and like little pumpkins and
stuff like that like showing up in the
stores then i'm just kind of like yeah
that's that's my time of year
and maybe i'd feel different if i lived
somewhere colder but i don't so
that was you always knew that was the
end of the shitty summer
hoodie weather is the best weather says
danny rolling i kind of feel like that
too i just like it it doesn't have to be
freezing cold i just like it to be
cold enough
that
you can wear like a sweater or a coat
and
you can have you can just kind of like
have some hot chocolate or some hot
coffee
and you're just comfortable you're not
really thinking about oh my god i'm
freezing my balls off but
other than that like yeah you're not
like really thinking about you're like
ooh kind of nippy outside it's like yeah
it's i just kind of wish it was like
that all the time to be honest with you
because i really don't like i don't like
being hot and
this is like the worst possible place on
earth i could have been born i guess
that i've kind of stuck here
but i don't know i was thinking about it
earlier because
i was watching uh jade the libra
and she was doing a little um
like get ready with me video like
putting her makeup on and like just
talking about some [ __ ] and she was
talking about how excited she was that
you know it was gonna be september soon
i mean she lives in kansas city i want
to say
so she said that it was actually like
nice outside like it was rainy and like
a little bit cool and i was like must be
nice i mean it's raining here too but
it's still hot like i said it's
almost 7 p.m it's quarter to 7 right now
and it's still light out and it's still
light out it's raining
and it's 87.
now i have not been outside today i try
to avoid it wherever possible
um
but i imagine it's pretty hot and muggy
outside because it's august and like i
said it's still gonna be hot like all
throughout september but at least the
nights start to cool off and the
mornings start to cool off
and
you know so you kind of get like more
slightly fall-ish kind of weather but we
don't really have that
drastic
a change like from
season to season which is you know
yeah tammy said any time of year when
you're not sweating to death yeah i'm
just i'm not a big fan i'm just not a
big fan of being
damp and sweaty and sticky and i just
don't like it i don't like it
so uh oh the raptors sent me
some pictures yesterday if
him and
my friend steve
was over at his place that's right he
said about that on wednesday yeah he's
shooting his second ar-15 and it's sick
too strong is it yeah it's sig 226 and
he has a little daughter with him it's
funny to see steve as a
in his 50s now so they said that i said
you tell that [ __ ] he needs to go on
hrt and dye his [ __ ] hair his hair is
[ __ ] white
look like [ __ ] johnny winners now
he's not an old man says he's not that
old come on he's 52. well maybe some
people like that man i actually had a
friend uh who her hair just went white
and she just left it and actually it
looks kind of cool i thought
because it was just all like silvery
white i thought it was pretty
but you know not everybody wants to
no wants to die i just shaved all my
[ __ ] hair off anyway my hair quality
was getting bad he's got a full thick
head of hair it's just this white
that's a trip
like i said i mean he's not dead
but yeah well that's something yeah he's
the same age as you right he's younger
than me he's younger than you by about a
year
well that's not that much down i mean
that's effectively yeah
yeah effectively the same age
wow
yeah tammy said when it's cold you can
add more layers but when it's hot you
can only take off so much exactly
exactly that's what i always said if
you're in florida you're walking around
in a [ __ ] bikini and you're still hot
there's really nothing much else you can
do you're just gonna be uncomfortable if
you're cold you can just put more like
long johns and [ __ ] like that on or more
blankets
i don't know i just i like cold weather
i just do
and i'm just like looking forward to
pumpkin spice everything and
just fall fall and winter that's my
favorite
spring and summer can suck it so like
you know half the year i'm just kind of
like
trying to hibernate trying to keep away
from all the [ __ ] oh like
that is it yeah that is a pretty strong
thing well i didn't maybe you need to
stir it that's all right we'll just kind
of just kind of shake it i can't shake
it it'll spray it
it won't work
i'm shaking it a little bit
it'll be all right well when it kind of
like melts and stuff like that it'll
kind of like all
run together
so when it when did when did steve come
here that was a while back about uh
because the kids did we have do we have
um did we have pokey then i don't think
we did no that was that was sick that
was pretty pooky
like i said we got pookie in the summer
of 2017 when she was a baby yeah
so that was before a pookie was even
born i remember when steve's kid was a
baby and that's what i'm saying well i
thought when he came to visit us yeah he
had pictures and the kid was a baby he
was a baby right so that was a while
back how old is the kid now
big enough to be running around shooting
guns
well how old is that that's about six
that doesn't mean anything okay
well that sounds about right then yeah
so that was probably like about six
years ago yeah
because i remember he came over and
visited but that was at the old house
clearly
john smith said i'm 42 and my luscious
locks are the envy of any maiden man
still i keep my hair long despite my
brother that went bald at 30.
what she's doing she's got the minty in
one hand and she's rubbing her face with
it i've never seen a cat be able to pick
something up in her hand like that just
push that i don't she's like white
now she got stuff she got she got all
self-conscious because we looked at her
yeah
and she just stopped and dropped it and
she was like what yeah am i doing
something bad she's got this little
thing it's
looks like we'll show it like pull that
there's a little
there's one of them on the cardboard
over there too i have her a new one that
i haven't like these little things yeah
they've got she [ __ ] loves these it's
no it's not it's mint it's catnip it's
not grabs it with one hand right here
and then just starts rubbing it on her
face basically like that too
she's like
yeah yeah yeah like she's really having
anywhere on her back rubbing it rubbing
her face with it and then if you look at
her she'll stop and she looks like what
well because she gets
like i said yeah she thinks that you're
mad at her she's doing something bad
that she's not supposed to be doing i
have to well i have to get new ones of
those i think i've mentioned this before
i usually get new ones i think they're
like two bucks or two three bucks or
something like that i get them from
chewie
and um
because she loves them and beijing loves
them too and beijing does the same thing
where she picks them up in one hand and
just rubs them all over her face
yeah and they're not catnip they're men
but catnip and men are in the same plant
family yeah they love it okay um
if you guys have any questions or any
topics or anything like that if you want
us to talk about just go ahead and drop
it in the comments section
you can inspire us to need some
interaction
sorry i was i was laughing about because
remember how i just said
uh how john smith said about how he uh
he kept his hair long despite his
brother
because he went bald at 30. yeah he said
i always insist we beat outside so he
can see it flow in the breeze
that's funny
that's funny i [ __ ] love that i love
that that's hilarious danny rowling said
pumpkin spice frosted shredded mini
wheat cereal is the [ __ ] you know what
i've been wanting to try that because
honestly i know it's very basic [ __ ] of
me but
man i love pumpkin spice [ __ ] i will eat
pumpkin spice anything and i love
frosted mini wheats like the plain ones
and i've never had the pumpkin spice
ones and i'm sure that would probably be
like the best [ __ ] thing ever like
maybe they'll have them at dollar
general maybe i should get a dollar
general and see if they have them or run
down to publix and see if they got them
or i guess i could just order my fam of
amazon if i'm being really lazy
that's what i usually is this sad i'm
too lazy
to drive to dollar general which is
literally next door like i could walk to
it if i wanted to yeah um it's literally
right next door and publix is maybe a
mile
maybe
um i'm literally 24 miles two miles you
think yeah okay yeah i've walked farther
than that though but i'm just saying
that it's like i could literally just
like it would literally like take me a
five minutes like drive there
and
if i want food like i'm like oh i should
get some oatmeal or i should get some
cereal or something like that i'll just
order it from amazon let's just have a
leave it at the front door that's how
[ __ ] lazy i am
i just i don't like to drive that's the
thing so what's everybody drinking go
ahead and uh tell us in the comments
section no i know you all are drinking
tammy said i grew catnip this year and
my cats couldn't be bothered with it
i've heard about a lot of people like
growing catnip i don't i wonder if it's
just maybe the catnip that they're
giving you to grow maybe they just don't
i don't know i tried to grow basil down
lower on the ground and [ __ ] beijing
ate it all i was going man where's the
why is the basil where's it going and i
saw her out there choosing beijing went
on the back porch and ate all all the
basil so i put it i had to put it higher
up where she couldn't get it i got it on
a big or higher but she can't get it now
she'll eat every bit of basil weird
she's a weird she's weird she likes it
chili basil she eats parmesan cheese
yeah
although i kind of feel like pookie
probably likes parmesan cheese too we
used to like sprinkle it on the floor
sometimes that both the cats would like
fight over it we haven't done that in a
while
but yeah they're both really into those
minty things and i've bought them like i
have to buy new ones like every month or
so because
they love them so much that they just
like rub them all over and they roll
around with them and they get like all
[ __ ] grubbies
and doom is drinking peach schnapps and
rum i wonder what that tastes like
something drinking water with apple
cider vinegar and fasting
i'm fasting and so lame oh that's okay i
mean you got to do what you got to do
gotta do what you gotta do
john smith said i bought combs just to
throw them away in front of him saying
my hair is too thick for them and he
dies
i love this whole i love this whole
situation i love it
oh my god that's so awesome i just i
love the shade i just love it
oh it's oh man
man i have such beautiful
thick
lovely hair that this comb is just not
it's not making it yeah
and then meanwhile
his bald ass is over there just going um
that's john smith drinking hot chocolate
but it's bedtime for me okay mmm hot
chocolate i love honestly i'm not
drinking but i'm about to get some beer
smoking a nightly blunt okay yeah you
know that's how it's fried he's gonna
get that american piss water beer
slits you want to get some schlitz man
do you remember like
on wednesday night's show yeah that was
oh somebody told me that killian's red
yeah was made by coors yeah it sounds
like cool okay i thought it might have
been miller but it's of course okay yeah
somebody told me like somebody commented
on yeah
that's beer that's a decent piss beer
yeah i don't mind that one actually like
i said i'm not a big uh beer fan and i'm
not a beer connoisseur so you know i'm
not one of those people who's like oh
it's like knowing all the difference
between the beers and stuff i honestly
couldn't be bothered um but
i but killians was okay killians is the
best
of the mass-produced cheap american
beers that have been killians
and sm and they they named that [ __ ]
they gave it a straight up mick [ __ ]
name
like a just uh just
trying to sound as irish as [ __ ] they
should have come like it came out of
paddy's yeah you call this [ __ ]
if they wanted to be anything yeah irish
mcpatty's mcdougals
with like a [ __ ] leprechaun yeah
i always wonder about that because i
always wonder
i'm sure like actual irish people are
just kind of like what the [ __ ] are you
all doing like st patrick's day with all
the leprechauns and the pots of gold
they're like [ __ ] all y'all y'all are an
irish yeah
why so well honestly where that came
from a lot of some of them were you know
it depends on where it is no i know that
the boston there's irish boroughs up
there that oh i know there are yeah but
i when i was in the uk like actual irish
people told me they thought it was
hilarious that like americans that had
never been to ireland in their lives
were calling themselves irish they're
like [ __ ] off it was identified never
race they'd never been here it was a
night it was like what are they even
talking about
being irish american uh in the 17 and
1800s was basically being a foreign race
it was it was a big deal like i get it
you know what i mean i get it because
there were like you know so many irish
people like immigrated here yeah they
weren't allowed to be in certain places
yeah and they got horribly discriminated
against yeah uh so you know i get that i
get that they banded together and did
that kind of stuff but i just but
nowadays like i said like actual irish
people that you know live in ireland
think it's funny that uh american bulger
was one of them and you know a lot of
the [ __ ] problems with the [ __ ]
that irish civil war that was going on
with the troubles
uh all that that was [ __ ] whitey
bulger and his gang was behind a lot of
that he just died a couple years ago
didn't he yeah they thought he might
have killed the lady of the dunes among
other people that dude and he was i
don't know if he did or not he was in he
was in league with a bunch of guys that
ended up in the in the fbi and
you know how crooked the american
[ __ ] government has always been but
um the ira was basically
being [ __ ] supported by whitey
bulger's gang
they were um
raising money in boston
and uh they were raising money for the
ira but they were doing it
surreptitiously
through
um well
the story was as [ __ ]
uh gambling and doing the numbers was
part of where it came and some of it may
have actually come from
rogue elements and kind of the cia maybe
had something to do with it
and they were taking that money and they
were buying uh ar ar180s which were
armalites eugene stoner's other design
not the m16 but he had one that came out
after that called the m18 or the ar-180
or ar-18 but they were taking the
civilian semi-auto versions
and buying them and stockpiling them in
certain places in the united states i
think it might have actually been boston
where they were stockpiling them and
having them smuggled out of boston
to ireland and they would disseminate
them amongst ireland irish republican
army and then uh like plans on how to
make [ __ ]
bombs and
explosives and
homemade flamethrowers and
so
and this was all coming out of irish
american
neighborhoods in boston it's where the
money was coming from
so yeah they were irish all right they
were very irish they were irish enough
to [ __ ] support the ira with [ __ ]
[ __ ] i mean but that was yeah but
that was like a long time ago i'm
talking about like modern day well
70s 80s i know but i'm talking about
like people that are okay when i was in
the uk like recently like in the 2000s
like in the 90s and the 2000s
like they just thought it was funny that
like
like i get that i know all about that
but i'm just saying
uh let's see uh zach says hahaha it's
all piss water i mean it is largely yeah
i'm not a big bear fan uh john smith
said and the bitchiest thing is this is
i love this so much the bitchiest thing
is long hair doesn't really suit me it's
just me trolling him yeah
they're up that's i i i admire your
commit your commitment
to despite i admire that there are two
american
bigger american beer companies that are
not piss water
yinling is not piss water it's it is
yingling is good i like it yeah it's a
low-cost high-quality high-value beer
you're getting a lot more than what
you're paying for out of yindling that
was america's oldest brewery
and they have a [ __ ] black beer and
they have a [ __ ] red beard it's
pretty yiddling is pretty good the other
one would be sam adams sam adams is
pretty good and they're they're big
that's
it's a big company bigger than a
european company probably but it would
be small compared to bush
you know anheuser-busch well the thing
about like bud and bush and stuff like
that is you can get those like
everywhere yeah that's like the thing
about yingling though and please correct
me if i'm wrong but i remember
that
my
sister's ex-husband
who was from philly
he was a big fan of yingling
now when him and my sister moved out to
denver you couldn't get yangling out
there because they weren't allowed to
sell it it was just like smokey the
bandit they didn't sell it west of the
mississippi river
so you couldn't get it out there for
whatever reason i don't know why why
but so every time that he came to
florida to visit his because his family
lived in deltona so every time they came
here to visit
they would stock up and he would fill
the car up with yingling so he could go
back with it
um but i don't know it might be
available on the other side of the
mississippi now but for whatever reason
they didn't have it but honestly
like i said i'm not a beer connoisseur
but yingling is good i mean honestly
beer
i've never found a beer that i liked
enough
to get me drunk
to drink enough to get me drunk you know
what i mean
yinling is comparable to it to one of
the
to kind of probably middle-ranking
european beer in terms of quality and
flavor it might be cheaper actually
yeah actually i haven't bought it in a
long time but i don't know how much it
is yeah sometimes i get it when i'm out
but it's better than i would say some of
the uh australian beers like i think
it's better than foster
you know
foster's isn't that good yeah
yeah foster's not i've only had it once
or twice but i don't remember you
being all that good being it wasn't
terrible it just wasn't all that
memorable yeah
yeah
it's better than that
i mean honestly like i said if i have to
drink beer which is never my first
choice
um
but if i have to drink it i'll usually
get yangling or
i'll get something that's like flavored
because like like i honestly what was
that [ __ ] beer that i got at will's
pub the other day that was like
hershey's yeah that was like a chocolate
beer it was pretty good that [ __ ] was
actually pretty yeah i was surprised i
thought it was gonna be gross but i'm
like well this is oddly delicious
although you gotta look at i like coffee
beers yeah i've gotta hand it to the
australians though fosters was better
than [ __ ] bud
a lot better but pretty much
everything's better yeah so you're
putting it there i don't even like
weather yeah
it doesn't taste like anything
it doesn't taste like anything
they don't know they're just drinking it
they don't know
and it's even it's not even that strong
like even if you want to drink it like
you want to get drunk like you have to
drink like a [ __ ] ton of it and it
doesn't taste that good yeah but they're
drinking it see
and it didn't cost much
i mean that's kind of i guess well the
thing about it though is if you grew up
somewhere that was the only beer that
was available or that was all you could
afford yeah then you probably got a
taste for it yeah you know yeah now um
that chocolate beer that you had that
was american that was american michael
brewery beer that's another thing
[ __ ] is that you know we have this
micro brewery beer you don't know where
it came from the quality is usually real
good
well like i said nowadays you can get
really good beer everywhere and honestly
will's pub one of their big things is
they like to have a variety of kind of
like artisan type of beers the thing is
those we've got thousands and thousands
of those companies that are all small
you can't remember them and you can't
find you can't reliably find the same
ones over and over again it's like
every [ __ ] few months you know you're
looking there's just all new beers where
are these coming from you know
you just don't know but they're all
consistently pretty good
yeah i've got some weird flavors you
know chocolate beer and
coffee beer i like those i like coffee
beers i like chocolate beers i like
pumpkin beers yeah
i like all that kind of stuff and they
have got a [ __ ] ton of [ __ ] ciders
pear cider
hard hard apple cider
i like that too
different yeah honestly that angry
orchard [ __ ] like if you if you don't
have that much money and you just want
something like to kind of get a little
bit of buzz yeah that angry orchard [ __ ]
is like that's pretty that's acceptable
somebody's mentioning [ __ ] black
velvet yeah you put angry orchard in
with in with uh
guinness stout did we have that john
smith said uh great guinness mixed with
champagne yeah probably good yeah
probably real good i don't i've never
had that we usually yeah we usually just
do guinness mixed with like apple or
pear pear yeah guinness is good with
pear hard cider
i think repair was my favorite i don't
know
i'm not even a big fan of pear but um
but that we used to get it at not will's
pub but what was that other tiny little
place down in the down in there yeah it
was good what the [ __ ] that's where they
had all they play cold wave and dark
wave yeah what the [ __ ] that tiny tiny
place
the falcon there you go and they yeah
they used to have parasiter and they
would mix it with that and that was like
really really good it's good it works
with apple too but we got a video of us
[ __ ] jamming out at the falcon uh
starry night's playing there live and
i'm up front [ __ ] remember [ __ ] we
were dancing gotham out and [ __ ] i
remember that remember that yeah i
remember that yeah i wonder if that
place is still open yeah i think it is i
think it's still spinning there yeah i
think it is yeah it's like an art
gallery nick mariano yeah it's like an
art gallery and a pub i mean it's tiny
tiny tiny it's little but yeah it's
super cool it's a really cool place
good clients yeah
yeah
they have a tiny tiny dance floor they
have like and the dance floor like they
have bands there sometimes the band kind
of has to play on the dance floor so
there's not like
you know they have kind of like it's a
little art gallery they do like a lot of
art uh you know local artists that like
put their stuff up there they have a
little bit of a shining motif which i'm
into
uh they have like a lot of shining
art like in the bathroom and stuff
and they usually have real good beer and
like i said friday nights they used to i
don't know if they do this anymore but
friday nights they would always do like
real obscure
like cold wave and
and it was like always really really fun
and i'm pretty sure
i don't know do they still do it
what's that night called uber bond
uber bond yeah
friday nights at the falcon
so we used to go there sometimes video i
think that video is on your channel in
it
uh maybe but i changed was that what was
the name of that old channel you had uh
well our gothic orlando
oh i don't know i don't know where it's
posted like my youtube channel that was
just old that was just under my name i
don't have that anymore because i
changed it out to one of my other
channels
so
but i don't remem that video wasn't on
there because i just downloaded a bunch
of videos off there the other day and
there was nothing that wasn't on there
so yeah
it might have been like on facebook or
something
it was one of those because i went i
changed
my cause i used to have like just a
jenny ashford youtube channel that i had
a few videos on from like five or six
years ago and i changed that out to
either scare salon or i think i changed
that one to crime immemorial but before
i did that i downloaded all the videos
that i had on that channel and that was
not one of them
so if it was i still have it yeah if it
was i still have it i saved all the
stuff i didn't delete it but
but i don't
that wasn't on there
michael shafer said tom do you remember
milwaukee's best uh david said
milwaukee's is almost as bad as yeah
yeah
dj maniac said you've used this title
already probably what title the title
that i it's
thinking of titles is hard
i know well i didn't know if i'd use
that exact terminology i knew that i'd
used
um working title edition it's like i
don't know i can never because i don't
know what we're gonna talk about so it's
always kind of hard for me to like come
up with a title every like single week
so i'm just
starting to get [ __ ]
yeah i'm trying to find that live video
it's uh
it wasn't on your facebook no no
i got him live at the kitchen
holy parachute doom says marketing uh
plus culturally there's big push for
crappy watery beer among macho types i
know
uh because it's perceived apparently as
a [ __ ] you to those who prefer imports
and specialty beers i always kind of got
that impression
that
people
uh certain types of people like would
drink bud or something like that just
because oh we just like this simple beer
and not like that snotty blah blah but
it's just kind of like yeah but that
beer is like [ __ ] weak sauce it's
terrible you know what i mean so
it's like all those hipsters are out
macho in you because their beer is like
way stronger and it tastes better so
it's just so who's like who's laughing
now it's just it's just shitty beer
that's what i mean yeah i i have never
understood
certain types of dudes that will just be
like well i i'll just drink like shitty
ass beer
because they think they're owning
the
i don't know
like beer snobs
i'm like okay i guess it's like drink
whatever crap you want i don't care i
have good stuff you're drinking it
ironically good for you
like good for you drinking shitty stuff
to like spite somebody that doesn't give
a [ __ ] about what they're drinking yeah
i just i don't know i don't get that
just i think that video is gone
i wonder where i wonder where i went to
i don't know
well don't look at me i'm like i'm
pretty sure you recorded it
yeah i think i recorded it but i don't
think i posted it on on my channel yeah
i don't think i might check well i told
you it's
it wasn't on my youtube channel because
i just downloaded all of the videos off
there the other day before i changed it
out
so i saved everything but it wasn't on
there
it wasn't on there
dj maniac says
i'm leaving in about an hour industrial
show in brooklyn tonight oh okay we'll
have fun with that have fun with that
uh hugo says modelo better than guinness
in my opinion i don't think i've ever
had modelo actually
no i don't have it it's not mine
i'm sure it's someplace
it's not on your youtube channel
don't you have an old youtube channel
somewhere
yeah yeah yeah i lost i lost control of
that channel a long time ago yeah what
happened there
i still had mine it's just
all that was on there was just like a
few random ass videos and like some old
commercials i'd done for some of my
books and stuff like that i downloaded
everything and then like i changed it
out to another channel
uh dj maniac said uh jenny i just dm'd
you a post about a game
called write and fight
okay i will look into that later that
sounds fun
less filling tastes great damn it
yeah i'm not i don't know
do you guys remember zema do you
remember zema yeah that [ __ ] i remember
that [ __ ] yeah
i don't know why i remembered that but
they they must have spent a lot of money
on life marketing back in the 90s
because i remember everybody talking
about that [ __ ]
and i remember drinking some well they
tried to make that [ __ ] a phenomenon
yeah they tried to make it well
well it worked for a little while and
yeah i think it was a flash in the pan
for a little while
but then
i mean i don't i don't really think that
it got to
to the cultural
uh you know heights of
white claw
you know what i mean where everybody's
drinking that [ __ ] but we didn't have
the internet back then so that's
probably why you could just have stuff
from like [ __ ] nobody likes sema yeah
it wasn't uh it wasn't good i i mean i'm
not [ __ ] i'm gonna give my experience
with the zima you're gonna get oh this
should be good this should be good
okay i have very limited experience with
you
i did drink it but
i i didn't really really feel one way or
the other about it
i had been up in korea for a year
up at camp greaves with the 506 on that
damn dmz
and
after i did my year there
me and basically everybody else from my
unit we got we all got
shipped out to the to fort campbell the
101st
and and joining the hunter first
can that was really where the 506
originally came from it was like the
sister division of the because we were
coming out of an airborne unit that was
attached to a leg unit a long story so
we go back to our mother division
and we all felt we all went to basic
training together we we were what was
called a cohort platoon where we were
all manufactured together all deployed
together and we moved around our whole
career together
same [ __ ] crowd of dudes okay it's
like we grew up together
so we get sent back to the to fort
campbell 101st and it was like it's like
we went to like we were coming back to
civilization
we were [ __ ] impressed because we had
been used and abused for about
for at least a year you know basic
trading and then right to the dmz
which was like a maximum security prison
and they were just running at 100 you
couldn't run older soldiers like that
because they would know better they
would want to quit
we it was like a ranger battalion so we
come back and we thought this [ __ ] was
civilized as a [ __ ] oh god man
this place is laid out it is [ __ ]
classy as [ __ ]
so
we all go to uh people are buying cars
and everything the whole idea of hey we
bought a car you know we can [ __ ]
leave we can [ __ ] leave the fort so
whole gangs of us were [ __ ] buying
these cars and carpooling and going
downtown to
to uh what was the name
not clarksville what was the [ __ ]
name of that damn
not nashville
man i can't remember there's a city
there's a city we used to go to take the
last train to clarksville
might have been clarksville that was the
moment no it wasn't clarksville
it wasn't nashville sorry we're just
[ __ ] with you i can't remember i
can't remember it but
it sounds crazy but it somethingville
it was somethingville
no it didn't end with the feel
okay but the little the little villages
ended with phil but anyway
we went to this [ __ ]
generic meat market jog boy bar all of
us went down there i hate those there's
like one of those yeah
yeah we all know we're starting we were
just you know we had only been in the
united states for like a couple months
we were just settling in and this was
like the first time we were all like
walking around like a bunch of noobs
[ __ ] right yeah
should we go to the foot and i [ __ ]
mosey up to the bar and they had a damn
lit up sign said zima
oh yeah and then underneath it was a
little bit it's wizardry yeah i was like
what and then underneath underneath that
was one of those little pretty
refrigerators with the glass doors sure
it's all lit up and had all these
bottles of sema
and the bottle was nice like yeah yeah
it had a nice bottle and it had like a
nice like kind of minimalist like yeah
it was all white and sparkly looking
[ __ ]
i remember that it looked like a damn
bottle of [ __ ] gin or something you
know a little bottle of gin like the
size of a coke bottle and i said zima
what is zima
and the bartender had to explain it to
me
[Laughter]
he says it's a
he goes it's a refreshing alcoholic
beverage and i said what's it made out
of beer
and he's like no
no it says it's vodka and goes no it's
it he's like it's a malt beverage yeah
i said what the [ __ ] is a malt beverage
what does that mean [ __ ] is a malt
beverage
and somebody's with me i don't remember
who was just one of my brothers was with
me you know and he's he's mystified too
what's a malt beverage what is this
stuff yeah it's all lit up and it just
said listen look he's trying to explain
this look just just give give us two
give us two so we're drinking it you
know and dude's looking at us meanwhile
everyone in the bar is looking at you
yeah yeah yeah well they probably not
really notice it they're drinking zima
yeah yeah but me no
you're like dude man probably nobody
though this is like spray
you know this is like sprite we were
impressed with it it was like shitty
spray yeah yeah yeah we got about we got
about three of them a piece we're
getting [ __ ] hammered on [ __ ]
[ __ ] zimas oh my god
somebody shows up this is the zima drunk
yeah they're sitting here what are you
doing i'm provoking your man yeah that's
what happened is that that's what
happened i yeah she wrote i couldn't i
could for yeah yeah we're sitting there
we drink like three different things
and um
[Laughter]
i think the wind went and his name is
win win showed up and he goes what you
drinking right there man [ __ ] did he
get it down dip in his muscles what
y'all drinking right there and i said
dude it's called a zima and we don't
know what it is it's like sprite because
man put that [ __ ] down that's for fast
put that [ __ ] down get it he got us off
that says no no no you get a gin and
tonic don't drink that [ __ ] wait wait
whoa whoa whoa whoa hold up hold up yeah
he told you to get a gin and tonic that
zima yeah
was for gays for gays yeah and then he
told you to get a gin and tom yeah it
was old man drink something about that
does not compete yeah i don't know
i thought that he was going to say
don't drink the zima yeah have a bud no
gin and tonic
genital that's what he was drinking
because he drank it it was a different
time yeah it was a different time he
drank it like i hey i'm not averse to a
gin and tonic i like a gin and tonic
every now and then although like i said
i can't have more than two or three
because they're very acidic and they
will make me throw up if i have more
than two
but i like them but it is kind of a
little bit an old man drink yeah it's a
little bit of an old man drink yeah well
it was sweet
it was kind of sweet yeah but we were
just [ __ ] pounding them
all right
and [ __ ]
i was pretty pretty sure it was wind
isn't it when it [ __ ] stopped all
that is that oh hell no oh hell no no
no no don't get me any more nozema this
is not allowed yeah yeah he said i told
him don't give them any more of these
just [ __ ] you can drink a man's drink
gin and tonic
[Music]
so we started drinking i just thought i
was only 22. i thought the story was
going to go a different way all right at
least thought no that he was going to go
without trinity zima like let's have
some whiskey
no or something like more macho no i
thought you know sonic is not very macho
well
no i don't really understand where
you're getting from it's because
because zima kind of tasted a little bit
like gin and tonic
he had his jacob dread of time
okay but still gin and tonic
i thought that he was presumably i
thought he was offended because he was
going to revoke your man card yeah he
did he revoked it
but revoking your main part and then
telling you to drink a gin and tonic
instead that's really that that's
reinstituted it's a little bit of
lateral movement that's really good
i thought he was gonna say drink some
shots of whiskey you [ __ ] no i
thought that's what he was gonna say no
he wasn't that uncouth
he has style oh he's not as uncouth as
i'm yeah he yeah he yeah
he has style he was he had stopped the
wind has to he just he's just like no
don't drink that
and that's what happened to zema
that's what happened to zima well that's
right that's why i think that business
model collapsed
well the thing about it though
is that zima
not zema particularly but that business
model kind of had the last laugh because
nowadays
you have like i said white claw you have
like all these kind of stuff that are
act i mean i will admit they taste a lot
better than zima um i don't know sema
tasted pretty good from what i remember
it was all right but uh but it was
essentially the same thing yeah but
nowadays um
no one really looks a scanty they might
like be like a hipster or whatever in
the 90s but yeah but back in the 90s you
were drinking azima people would think a
certain kind of way
in 92 that was some experimental [ __ ] we
didn't even know what a malt beverage
was
the only thing close to malt beverage
would be like malt liquor and that guy
drew the equivalent because it's malt
liquor you know like cold 45 i was like
oh okay yeah because i drank that
hell yeah
see i i was another thing you know i
almost had my white card remote provoked
for drinking [ __ ] malt liquor back in
the day there's another thing yeah you
had several cards revoked yeah you're no
longer white it was a drink you drink
them all liquor that's this that's a
crazy dynamic back then but the thing is
those [ __ ] malt liquor was better
than piss water beer
brother knew that oh no i will agree
with that oh yeah
i mean i [ __ ] i would much rather drink
cheap as colt 45 yeah it was
than bud it was heavy and smooth and not
even a contest not even a contest it was
heavy and smooth and [ __ ] very kind
of strong you could drink a lot of it
and [ __ ] get real [ __ ] up that it
was a better experience than drinking
[ __ ] bud
king cobra that was another one we used
to drink i think somebody mentioned that
right oh did it yeah and there was
another one called something bull boom
not red bull but well obviously but
something boy it had a red bull on it
though it was a silver can with a red
bull and it was something a bull
you guys might remember that was another
one we used to get that you show up at
the barracks and say yeah we'll drink
that
but showed up in the army got a bull on
it so it's allowed
[Laughter]
gotta remember you know [ __ ] infantry
barracks is a mixture of everybody it's
it's white guys latinos and black guys
and [ __ ] sometimes the black dudes
will score a whole bunch of [ __ ] malt
liquor and start handing it out you
drank it yeah hell yeah well i mean you
know any alcohol is i'm not gonna turn
down any alcohol come on yeah right you
guys know me right
yeah but i will not i'm not gonna deny
that certain kind of alcohol maybe less
so than now than you know used to be
but certain kind of alcohol have a
certain kind of like um
social cachet to them yeah
like if you see like i said i think it's
less
i don't think it's as prominent as it
used to be no because now because well
because now everybody has the internet
and everybody has their own little thing
going on and most people are just kind
of like hey man you do you whatever
which to me that's like better but back
in the day
like you were drinking the wrong thing
everyone's gonna be like what the [ __ ]
are you drinking um lionex worry said
gin and tonic is very little pinky in
the air
and then john smith said i always
associate gin with girls crying on the
stairwell at a party thing and that's
when he left me
gin and tonic in the uh i don't know
about nowadays but i kind of feel like
gin and tonic
has always been kind of like an old
person's drink like like an old
fashioned [ __ ] or something like that
now
old-fashioned um that's kind of had a
resurgence lately because that's more of
like uh you know because people have
been rediscovering like old drinks from
the old days and that's kind of like a
thing now but i still kind of feel like
gin and tonic is like an old man i
remember what it was i like them though
it was called schlitz malt liquor bowl
that's right i remember oh yeah yeah
yeah i remember it was pretty good i
liked it
but i was up there in the [ __ ]
barracks drinking i think it was king
cobra
and my boy bear grog i'm sticking
drinking this she's just been drinking
that king cove before that's what car
brought it you know car was a black
soldier he's a buddy bars that's a car
brought that [ __ ] [ __ ] it's just let
me drink that [ __ ] next thing you know
next thing you know be able to smoke
smoking swisher sweets and [ __ ]
man you can still buy those at
convenience stores next you're gonna be
smoking for like 50 cents or a dollar a
year i don't know how much they are
right so i got i got white checked i got
white checked mama [ __ ] butt
but this was all part of the game like i
said it was so many cards you got
revoked it was all part of the game
you're no longer a white man yeah yeah
it was yeah i mean it's a good thing
that you're an honorary mexican because
you have that to fall back on you know
that to fall back on that was not that
was all part of the 90s army game it was
all part of the art of the 90s army game
we [ __ ] with each other incessantly
it was
okay college hazing wasn't [ __ ] on 1990s
army infantry in an airborne unit
constant [ __ ] hazing constant
psychological warfare constantly punking
a [ __ ] out constant [ __ ] it
was just constant constant
but we loved it
we loved it we would try to
we would try to engineer new ways to
[ __ ] with each other it was funny though
man
and you had to learn to take it if you
got mad it was a sign of weakness
you had you couldn't get mad i mean but
you do understand that women have their
own thing of that and i and i would
argue
that women's psychological warfare is
way worse than probably probably
way worse
we know how to like wound you for life
you know what i mean because well and i
think that's because women like actually
know you so they know
all of your vulnerabilities so they know
like how to get to you like so it will
it's for maximum like trauma
yeah you know yeah uh let's see where uh
where was i
oh i just saw something that i wanted to
say um
tga maniac said zima and taco bell and
doom were a friday night staples yeah
high school yeah yeah that sounds like a
lot of people i mean
i was out of high school by 1990 like i
graduated in 1990 so that was a little
bit past my time
but i do kind of feel like
i just remember like zima being a big
thing and i honestly i think that i was
when did zema come out does anybody know
90s
1991 92 run that time to 92. i don't
know like i said i wasn't a big drinker
in high school i didn't really start
drinking until later like until i was in
my 20s or 30s
like i don't know i just never got into
it
so
i don't even think i
drank any zima until later because i got
curious about him like what the [ __ ]
like why is
this [ __ ]
all these commercials about maniac came
out and said king cobra was off what do
you say king cobra was awful what do you
say yeah king cover was not awful it's
[ __ ] awful and they still sell it in
the hood over here along with st ides
yeah it's saying nice yeah i remember
that one too we used to drink that yeah
they still got that yeah we just drink
that one too
king cobra they got that at the liquor
store like down at the [ __ ] at the
[ __ ]
king cobra was good when you were in
when you were in your 20s in the army
but you like i said if you're if you're
a caucasian though you had to lie and
say you didn't like it but you were
still [ __ ] drinking it like hell yeah
we drank it when it was around we drank
we liked i liked it
i'd be doing billy dee williams
impersonations [ __ ] drinking [ __ ]
[ __ ] colt 45 and [ __ ]
did tom think he was lando calrissian
[ __ ] man i wish that was lando
calrissy man [ __ ] he was very cool i get
that yeah yeah
wishing i was call weather is that big
[ __ ]
he was bad ass man [ __ ] i saw
predator one that was it man i was a car
weather fan after that
but uh no man [ __ ]
we had all that [ __ ] in the army it was
a frat boy it was a frat boy experience
we made frat boy frat boys are [ __ ]
compared to us man but well
they're just kind of [ __ ] yeah gonna
say
yeah [ __ ] not a fan
airborne infantry airborne infantry
barracks were [ __ ]
there was [ __ ] and span highly
disciplined but it was when we were off
it was [ __ ] chaos
absolutely well i one thing like feeds
into the other thing yeah absolute chaos
yeah
and uh
john smith said lando can pull off
wearing a cape one of the very few men
that can remain straight and still yeah
and no one like questions anything but
he's got a cape on no one's no one's
even he's a man of great responsibility
that's what i'm saying it's like it
doesn't occur to anybody to like
question that that
decision so honored to have you with us
up here in the clouds [ __ ]
[Laughter]
right
michael schaefer said tom rodriguez yeah
oh yeah oh my god that's what my star
calling you know roswell
[Laughter]
you're [ __ ] bringing it back odds are
i'd say is it weight is it ides or items
i thought it might have been ives with a
v it's been a long time i remember that
one i don't know it's like that yeah and
we tried all that [ __ ] man it all came
through the barracks all that oh and we
tried it all and uh but yeah as soon as
alcohol comes in yeah like yeah
let's try that out okay that that works
it was
it was good malt liquor was [ __ ] good
uh for especially for the price
i mean for [ __ ] that was cheap
malt liquor
gave a lot of bang for the buck
the flavor was there it was a little bit
thicker
um it was better than piss water beer
and you gotta remember it's it's
competing within a certain price range
yeah i mean if you only have so much
money it's like you're trying to get the
best drunk and the best taste right for
the money for the money yeah which is
all that much yeah i i'd agree with you
on that score yeah and then and the cans
were bigger yeah
you got more and it tasted better yeah
right now if you start moving up in
price you know all that stuff kind of
goes into the background but you got to
be you got to be reasonable
if you own a limited budget you you want
the most bag for the buck and in terms
of flavor and [ __ ]
the drunk and the experience of [ __ ]
king cobra man [ __ ] yeah we liked
king cobra i don't think i've ever had
king cobra king coke
i mean it was thick it had a good head
on it a lot of foam
it was wait what is it exactly it's it's
malt liquor beer oh okay it was uh it
was thick it had a good head hit a good
head of foam on it if you poured it
it was um
heavy
so it was filling it was uh it had a
rich
malty
flavor like almost like a bison beer
and uh alcohol very alcoholic
it was uh and it was real smooth it
didn't have a dry aftertaste to it it
was very much like a sweet german vicine
beer
but it was malt liquor
probably totally artificial
probably probably toilet
uh but it was it was a good product and
it had a [ __ ] impressive can it was
red and black with a damn [ __ ] black
cobra on it and [ __ ]
it was marketed towards teenagers i
think well yeah in your early 20s this
is a macho [ __ ] you know what i mean
yeah i can't go bro you know
you knew what they were doing that was
what they drank of eating boys yeah [ __ ]
was [ __ ] ghetto man
it was good
i don't think i've ever had it i
actually i don't even remember ever
seeing the can i'm sure i've seen that
but they didn't really make an
impression
kailyn higgins says most women genuinely
mean what they say when they cut into
each other and those jokes are never
forgotten yeah that's what i'm saying
like uh honestly i think
and this is a general statement but i
think women are better at psychological
warfare
uh than men are and and that's usually
because
of women tending to be more empathetic
so they know a lot more about their uh
friends and so they know exactly what to
say to wound that person forever
so if you turn against a person that you
used to be friends with then man you can
say some [ __ ] that will stick with them
for years which is terrible but
that's just you know
i would argue that even though dudes are
more physically violent generally
i think women are more uh
psychologically
mean
generally that's i don't think that's
true right across the board but i think
that's
largely true
uh michael schafer said for a cheap
drunk in college we would go with mad
dog 2020. yeah i think i brought that up
on a wednesday show okay two dollars and
30 cents a bottle would [ __ ] you up
oh right right oh okay i know what
you're talking about that is a 90s
vintage king i recognize that now oh let
me try to guess
i never drank that i've never you can't
i don't know if you guys can see the
color but it's it's black and gold okay
badass gs750 said tom don't forget to
say hi to sarah she's at work uh she
loves you guys hey how you doing sarah
here's the marketing campaign look at
the face the king cobra that's what he's
like
you got [ __ ] african-american house
going on with his beautiful [ __ ]
african-american look at his expression
well you can't really see it he says
don't let the smooth taste fool yeah
that's right this says it's time to
change from harsh malt liquor taste to
cold malt liquor satisfaction and a
smooth taste king cobra king cobra
premium malt liquor a new
breed of malt liquor from anheuser-busch
this expression yeah look at this thing
look at this experience it's cracking me
up like that's right man he's just like
[ __ ] right mm-hmm yeah
yeah oh my god that's like that's making
me laugh now they've kind of like
king cobra's upped its game now okay now
here's what what the new bottle looks
wait let me see that
okay that's nice too yeah that's nice
too so it's anhyzer bush product
i know i don't love it that looks a
little retro but not in a way look at
the cobra though man it looks like
something on the side of a motorcycle i
mean okay and then there's the can okay
they can't the can is cool
i like six percent alcohol by vlog i'm a
graphic designer if you guys can kink
i've been doing that [ __ ] for like 25
years now makes me want to drink some of
that
we'll see well then it's done its job
it's done its job yeah i'd like to try
some of that job
been a long time here look at that one
this is
in a champagne bottle
cobra gold that i like that's classic
[ __ ] right look at that it's kind of
minimalist but i like it i like it hell
yeah i like it oh yeah
like i said i've been a graphic designer
for like 25 years
so
i'm very into
people's
uh
the way they present their product i'm
really into package design i'm really
i'm not a big fan of minimalism and i
kind of feel like minimalism is kind of
like the way that people are going
nowadays but
sometimes it works though okay look
all right
here's here's the [ __ ] classic cult
45 with billy dee williams
okay
[ __ ]
say
he was a spokesman for a long time
that's right
yeah he's like yeah i'm pouring this in
the glass yeah and look i remember that
can remember that can
well yeah i remember that yeah
i didn't drink it but i remember that oh
no i remember that yeah well that's a
good can because it's very bold it's
like the name is big and it's like
there's good contrast i'm into that yeah
and then now see they're up in the game
now the high gravity colt 45 that's
right they're aggressive trying to go
for like a slightly more scale classy
yeah i see that see black and gold that
makes you want to drink that makes you
want to try that
i kind of preferred the old design
though it was a lot more impactful i
feel i think the old design looked a
little too sports sportsy for me a
little bit too baby well yeah this is
morning
but
i would argue that that design is a
little generic because a lot of other
uh liquor brands like have that kind of
like black and gold kind of like uh
branding yeah so i kind of feel like it
doesn't stand out as much
you really have to kind of
i don't know man like i said i you know
i've been doing this like work like for
a long time so it's like really hard to
like stand out in the market
you know what i'm saying i can't believe
it's 91 out there
my [ __ ] still says 87 but it hasn't
changed it still says rain off and on
and i don't even think it's raining
anymore is it
i don't hear any rain that doesn't mean
it's not raining
kalyn says i wish companies would bring
back intricate artistic designs in their
products instead of going for minimalism
yeah i kind of feel like minimalism has
been
the overriding
aesthetic
probably for the past god as long as i
can at least for the past decade for as
long as i remember but you do have kind
of like outliers
um it's not really because of the
internet because of the uh you know uh
[ __ ] that's more diversified nowadays
i kind of feel like you don't see
these overriding aesthetics like you
used to see back in the old days so yeah
there's like a big
trend of like minimalism but also
there's like a lot of like little mini
trends of like doing like really
elaborate stuff which i'm more into
i do like minimalism in some
applications but
honestly i don't know like as a graphic
designer i always kind of feel like
minimalism
i know this is maybe
i don't know i always just kind of feel
like whenever i'm doing something and
people want something minimal i always
kind of feel like i'm cheating because
it's like
it feels like a lot less work to me you
know i don't say i'm not saying that you
have to make everything super elaborate
but i don't know
i do like i do like minimalism in some
maniacs
he's getting he he's getting bent out of
shape he says king cobra tastes like
motor oil and death no it does not
and he goes it's like putting perfume on
a pig
there you know repackaging [ __ ] kick
over
he goes
i don't care how you package it king
cobra [ __ ] is filed
dude that's not how i remember i've
never had well yeah but i've never had
it so i can't say you haven't had it in
probably like
many many years i wouldn't mind i
wouldn't mind going by and buy another
can of it and see what it tastes i mean
i've known you since 2011. yeah i've
never earlier and you haven't drunk it
since i've known you so that's been a
long time no last time i had that was
been in the [ __ ]
93 so you might drink it now and be like
oh my god i'm gonna like he's right that
is bile but it was um it was a flavor of
its time
all right and it was competing against
other products of its in its price range
which were probably all they were all
[ __ ] terrible
a lot of times i was already drunk when
i started drinking
that's enough so yeah so you're maybe
not the best judge
of the aesthetic qualities
i'd like to try the taste of the [ __ ]
it's anheuser-busch at least at least
i'm going to buy i'll buy you one next
time i'm out right it's strong it's from
the modern man they can drink it on the
show
it's the black edition see what it is
they know you have to get the fans
african-american it is africa marketed
towards the african-american market they
were drinking malt liquor
all right so um but the big company says
well this is you know black people like
this this we're going to give them and i
remember liking it okay
i thought it was better than um
regular piss water
but i haven't had it in a while i'm
gonna go look they just
companies are smart
you know they look at
they do market research they see who's
buying and then they market to the main
buyer well yeah so that that's what you
do to maximize your your your your
selling potential but i remember it
being high quality and tasting good
but it was a long time ago a long time
ago and you were mostly drunk when you
mostly dropped my stuff right
so it's better
i can tell you i can tell you now i can
tell you right now it's better than
[ __ ] budweiser
well i don't think anybody's going to
argue with you about that because
budweiser is uh kind of terrible also
i don't remember being like budweiser
being terrible i just remember it being
not tasting like no it's weak weak and
dry tasting and just that's what i'm
saying i just remember it being just
kind of like lit now i also remember
higher grades of budweiser and miller
being better
than than the low grade well and i kind
of feel like lately they've kind of
upped their game because they know
that's the way the winds are blowing you
can't do that anymore you can't just
yeah everybody's like into craft beers
now it's like everybody's kind of a beer
connoisseur now so you can't like get
away with that kind of crap anymore but
has has king cobra and cole 45 have they
upped their game too
see i will ha
i'd like to [ __ ] taste it now let's
see
like i said i kind of feel like one of
the things that we've talked about this
in regards to food
is that in a lot of ways
yeah you can complain about certain
restaurants or certain uh you know
prepared food that you buy in the
grocery store or whatever like tasting
like ass but
um
back in the 70s and 80s when we grew up
a lot of that stuff tasted kind of like
crap and you didn't really have anything
to compare it to i know what i'm going
to do but nowadays you do so you can't
really get away with it which i think is
kind of better across the street from
the biker bar got a little [ __ ] um
country uh
liquor store with beer
i bet you they got cake cobra malt 40
cocoa are you gonna go i'm gonna buy
some okay first and then we're gonna
taste that [ __ ] on a friday on the next
side next
i will [ __ ] taste it okay don't
forget though all right don't forget
we're gonna do a taste test oh wait i
got a pen i gotta pick that [ __ ] down
we're gonna i'm gonna read it give me
some paper give me some paper
i got paper over there somewhere on my
left there we go there's a yeah that'll
let you taste it too
well i didn't taste it before so i'm not
gonna we're just
yeah we're gonna like what's the [ __ ]
call now
[ __ ] k i don't know tank cover okay i
got king cobra coal 45 i need a bottle i
need i need colt 45
yeah
okay we're going to do that like we'll
do that next friday don't forget this
will be super fun this will be fun get
some squishies like i said i don't know
what the [ __ ] tasted like before so i'm
not going to be surprised
get some black and miles
hold on let me go get some uh
let me go get some more mike says
budweiser is good for washing your car
yeah i mean probably
i will never understand like honestly i
will never understand why budweiser
became like
i don't know if it's so much this
nowadays but i kind of feel like back in
the old days like budweiser was like ooh
the american beer or whatever that was
like what all the kind of like
rednecky kind of dudes drank and stuff
and i was just kind of like one it's
super weak and it doesn't really taste
that good but also
i don't know it's just i don't know why
that became like a cultural thing it
probably isn't anymore but i kind of
feel like it used to be and i will never
understand why that happened
i never understood it's not good it's
not a good beer
uh caitlyn said did most of those
designers move their businesses to
places like etsy probably
i don't know like i said there's
there's so much out there that like i
said i tend to do more elaborate kind of
stuff when i design when i have to do
something minimalist it's like really
stressful for me because
it's not
my aesthetic and it's like whenever i'm
trying to do something really minimalist
like i said i always feel like i'm kind
of cheating because i'm kind of like i
feel like i'm not really doing anything
that somebody else couldn't do like on
their own
but you know what i mean
um let's see uh tom should do a taste
testing on the side track show yeah i we
will i wrote it down
if he goes and gets that stuff
i'll drink some of it i'll give my
honest opinion like i said i don't have
any dog in this fight i have never drunk
king cobra or cruel footy
cult 45 like either uh
either one of those ever in my life as
far as i can recall
so
i can give an uh unbiased opinion about
how they teased so we'll see
i'm not picky though i should say i'm
not like a big connoisseur about it
uh granthar says is there a plan b if
the podcast thing doesn't pay the bills
honestly um
like i said tom's already got
money he's retired so he uh gets a
monthly check not a check but you know
so he gets that i'm really the only one
that has to rely on the stuff it's not
just a podcast i do graphic design work
i have uh you know [ __ ] for my books and
stuff like that
so
i don't know i've thought about it i've
thought about well
i guess i could maybe like i don't know
i might like pick up another gig like
driving for instacart or something like
that but i also do i do uh transcription
also but sometimes when i have time like
if i have uh a few hours available like
i'll kind of like put up the
transcription app and
you know if i can transcribe some videos
and stuff like that make a few bucks
here and there so i do that as well
because
you know
i mean i'm
i can type fast and i'm really good at
grammar
so
uh so i got in with that so i do that as
well
what's the most overrated horror movie
of all time ooh
overrated that's a hard question
most overrated the thing about it is
that i kind of feel like most horror
movies that people have like a really
high opinion of i usually also have my
opinion of them like i think they
have earned that high opinion like
they're
you know they're allotted for a reason
hmm
oh i got one um
and this is more
fairly more recent
i didn't love
paranormal activity
i know that a lot of people like we're
really into that oh my god it's like one
of the best found footage movies ever
and it was like a huge phenomenon and
everything like that and maybe that
wasn't so much among horror fans i don't
know maybe that was like more people
that weren't super into horror that was
just like more general
but
i like paranormal activity but
the
the amount of
buzz that it got i think was like way
way way like outer proportion to how
good the mood it was a good movie
but i've seen like way better ones than
that so that's what that's my answer
that's my answer
uh grandparents asked what's the most
overrated horror movie of all time
i said it's hard for me to like say like
the old ones because i think those all
like deserve their reputation
but one that i think is overrated is the
first paranormal activity i like that
movie i'm not saying that but i think
that it's overrated in the terms of
i don't think it's overrated in the
terms of like the cultural impact that
it had because it obviously had a really
big one
um as found footage film but watching it
it's scary but i've seen like way better
and way scarier so there's that so i'm
going to say paranormal activity how is
the best way to protect your home from
emps in a nuclear war
that was a question no no uh you don't
you don't
you just get used to like not having
internet or power or anything like that
yeah yeah i'm gonna do the taste test
and tammy also said uh when he asked is
there a plan b of podcast things to pay
the bills
and i already answered that tammy said
tom's going to sell his body the yeah
well the podcast doesn't pay the bills
anyway
i mean like i said and i told him it's
like well for you you don't need
anything to pay the bills because you
already get i mean i'm medically retired
90 of my active duty he's medically
retired from the military so he doesn't
need anything to depend on the bills i
get full medical money he already pays
the bills yeah it's just it's just my
ass that has to like pay bills because
this is podcast
um
i do freelance graphic design and my
books
and that's pretty much it like i said
i'm kind of working without a net i
don't really have anything i don't have
any unemployment i don't have anything
like that no so
jenny's main income really is from
graphic design she studied graphic
design clients and stuff and then
podcast is podcasting the show and as
much work as she puts in it
that's side money i mean i mean that's
probably my second biggest
it depends on the month though because
sometimes sometimes it does some months
like graphic design i don't get as much
stuff
like i do a lot of freelance work
but sometimes
you know i i only have like maybe five
or six like really big clients
and sometimes they don't have anything
that month if we do bad
on ad revenues and super chats yeah we
feel it
we feel it oh yeah big time yeah big
time because the thing about it is that
but it's only like one quarter of
[ __ ] what it costs to keep everything
running and it's one quarter of [ __ ]
the total income i mean because you're
lucky because you have i'm a half of it
i mean you have like something you have
an x amount that comes in every month
yeah and i i never know like how much
i'm going to get from month to month
because sometimes if i get a lot of ad
revenue or if i get a lot of or we get
new patrons or something like that like
it'll be a lot and sometimes i get a lot
of graphic design work or sometimes i'll
sell more books than usual like that
month but i never know like how much
money i'm gonna get for a month and to
be honest like other than
um
all the household bills we have to pay
like the mortgage and the electric and
everything like that i have a [ __ ] ton
more bills than you have because i have
a car and you don't enter so i have to
pay yeah i have to pay the car insurance
my car is paid for but i have to pay for
the car insurance yeah and i also have
to pay i have like a [ __ ] ton of credit
cards so i always have to i six or seven
credit cards so i always have to like
pay at least the minimums on those and
so that's like a big thing and i also
pay for other [ __ ] for you know having
to do with the podcast like my websites
and
all that other kind of stuff i have to
pay for
uh
stock photo sites i have to pay for
graphic design kind of stuff so a lot of
like business business expenses that i
have to pay for here's the deal if if if
the economy goes more south which it
probably will
and we really start [ __ ] hurting for
money
well all i would do is just go to work
for the [ __ ] state of florida
all right
just because i'm medically retired
doesn't mean that i can't work for the
state
matter of fact i get preferential
treatment
[ __ ] i can also work for the feds if
i want to like i said i might have to go
work at dollar general or like work for
instagram or something
so because if you're medically retired
you have a disability they'll find a job
for you yeah all right they'll make up a
job for you and that could be another
[ __ ] grand a month
but the thing is i wouldn't be able to
be on the show i'd be gone all the time
and if i wanted to i could play the
[ __ ] va system
which is say look i got anger management
problems they go well we're going to
send you to a damn anger management
program it lasts a month so they'll send
you they'll ship me out it's kind of
like they put you back on active duty
they ship you out send you some facility
with a bunch of other veterans and you
[ __ ] go to these anger management
courses and from that [ __ ] drink all
night have a [ __ ] party really that's
what it is
and then you come back and they [ __ ]
cut you a 3 dollar check for being gone
but you're gone for a month
yeah there's a bunch of games but i
don't play those games all right i mean
if you really needed the money yeah it's
kind of like
it's kind of like milking the cow you
know what i mean and i'm just i'm not
yeah it costs you a lot of time i'm just
not that greedy and
they got dude they got dudes like me
that spend their whole [ __ ] careers
and their whole lives lying to try to
get some of that damn special program
money
i could do it if i wanted to but i just
don't do it i'd rather be at home
and [ __ ] just get my pay and [ __ ]
helping jenny and doing the shows and
[ __ ] then going out to the clubs and
stuff and rather just minimize spending
more than trying to maximize income
yeah because i mean i feel like i'm
[ __ ] over the taxpayer because it's
y'all's money
that yeah that's the thing you know what
i mean well i think that's kind of why
even though at times in my past i've
probably qualified for
for wic or for welfare or something like
that i just never did it because i just
felt bad it's not really in our nature
to [ __ ]
put a hand out like that
i mean i would if i absolutely really
needed it but we don't really need it
but
i don't i mean i don't know it the thing
about it is that
i don't know i because i grew up
um poor
so i'm kind of used to it's not gone
it's not fun i'm not saying that and
you're constantly stressed out but i'm
kind of used to
going from
not even like month to month but like
day to day it's like just today
i'll get through
this day it's like if i can make x
amount of dollars you know that's good
like whatever it is that i'm doing um
you know and i'm i ate today so it's
good so it's just kind of like i try to
like
see things from that perspective another
thing that i could do is just right up
here at the corner not even a quarter
mile up the street there's a nursery
the nursery that'll pay you by the uh by
the peace
they have mentally handicapped people in
there
moving [ __ ] plants and loading trucks
yeah they just pay people to come in and
like if i wanted to i could do a chair
you could just go up there and get paid
like yeah go up there and pay you should
i i could probably do that too if i had
to yeah it wouldn't it wouldn't pay the
bills here but it would it would make a
difference on top of the other checks
that i get and [ __ ] from from the
federal government but what i would do
is [ __ ] i thought about it recently
but
because you can come and go as you
please you have to worry about hours
i'll go down there and [ __ ] take my
steroids and do my workouts over there
[ __ ] moving trees we'll see there you
go i'm loading trucks
it's just right it's literally right
there it's a massive massive nursery and
i don't know how much they pay per piece
but
i imagine [ __ ] i could probably get a
pretty good workout and probably make
[ __ ]
forty dollars in a [ __ ] four or five
hours
maybe or maybe a hundred dollars and
[ __ ] you know eight hours or
something i don't [ __ ] know i don't
know what they pay
but it'd be you know probably get a
workout
yeah and it's not like you're under a
contract if you didn't like you didn't
have to go back
i mean like i said in some ways and i
was thinking about this earlier today i
mean i spent a lot of my life like i
said i went to college for graphic
design i worked as a graphic designer in
many many large companies for you know
years and years
in some ways that's better because you
have like a place to go every day and
you have like benefits and you have all
this you know you know how much you're
gonna get every month
so there's that but
i was honestly never i'm just not the
kind of person that likes
i don't like being told like what to do
on a particular day or what time i got
to show up or anything like that i've
just never been that kind of person
so i always had trouble like
keeping regular job i did i mean i've
kept regular jobs for a very very long
time
but
i don't like it i just i don't like
being told what to do i don't like it's
like oh you have to show up here at 8
a.m every day i don't like that crap
it's like look it's like if i get the
[ __ ] done what does it matter yeah if i
do it at eight a.m or if i do it at like
three people yeah i was talking about
that [ __ ] it doesn't really matter
like right because that nursery doesn't
have bosses you just come in and do
whatever piece work that's what i'm
saying whatever you want to do but i
will i will say though that working the
way i work which is having basically
like three separate gigs
that are
not dependent on anything like i said i
don't have i don't have anything i don't
have any insurance i don't have uh you
know any kind of uh retirement i don't
have anything
um so it's kind of like working without
a net and i don't really know how much
i'm gonna make from month to month
because some months are good some months
not so much
so it kind of goes so i'm like
constantly stressed out but
i don't know if i'd want to go back
though i don't really like stuff being
really structured i like structure but i
like the structure to be
structure that i
made she got her own studio her own
office here she runs this [ __ ] i want my
own schedule
i don't like my schedule imposed on me
from outside yeah um you know i and you
know i have a schedule it's like i get
up very very early i get like six seven
in the morning i come in here i work for
like three or four hours then i do my
you know 20 miles on my bike and i do
all that kind of stuff you're doing 20
now yeah okay good
yeah 20 miles every day yeah 20 miles
and wait how long does it take for 20
days 20 miles about 45 minutes
about 45 minutes 45 47 minutes something
like that
yeah okay yeah all right um you know but
so i do that so yeah so i get up really
early sometimes when it's still dark
come in feed pookie make a cup of coffee
and i'm like okay i'm gonna work for
like three or four hours i usually like
catch up on whatever to do edit videos i
have to edit like any of that kind of
stuff then i'm like okay i'm gonna do
bike for 45 minutes then i go take a
shower put makeup on i film any videos
that i have to film that day
and because you know you guys know i do
i do a lot of them
so
so i'll do that and then usually we'll
have lunch so i do all of that like
before lunchtime
and
it's
tiring but
it's my own
schedule like that's me imposing that
that's not somebody else imposing it i
don't really like somebody else's
schedule imposed on me but i will
absolutely put a
draconian schedule on myself
because it's just me doing that yeah so
you know what i mean i just don't like
it imposed from outside
i feel like i get a lot more work done
when someone else isn't telling me what
to do when i'm just telling you what to
do
because i kind of have this weird thing
where
i don't know this is just me but it's
just and this is kind of why
why is it that jenny now has three
[ __ ] channels going
because i'm not happy
with just one thing it's not enough i
have to have i'm like well i have a i
have like
other time i could do this and that and
the other thing i have a million ideas i
have to do this and that and the other
and it's like then i
just pile things on top of myself and
then i stress myself out but then i have
to like back up and say well you did
that to yourself though right you know
what i'm saying you know how i do yeah
he knows how i do you've known me for a
long time yeah
tell her stop doing it but she does what
she wants to do well in a way it's
it's stressful but
you have to do it yeah yeah grandpa's
talking about his [ __ ] he's doing he's
done that rowing machine all the time
i'm telling you grab this with the same
age get on hrt
your progress will [ __ ] accelerate a
lot
the body will respond a lot better get
on hrt
jeffy art said i also got creative
adhd
i mean
this i don't know this is really weird
because for a long time when i was
younger
i always wanted i was like oh man i have
all these ideas for books and stuff like
that but i was always i don't know if
i'd necessarily call it lazy
but i never got it done
it wasn't laziness it was
i didn't want like i was like well i
don't want to write anything down
because it's not going to be
good
when i write it down and
so it's not good enough so i'm not going
to bother you know what i mean so it's
not necessarily laziness it was more
like insecurity
but once i got past that hurdle
like in the late 1990s
and started just like writing by saying
like [ __ ] it and just like writing books
and then i started writing all kind of
stuff but then it kind of switched into
another mode where
now i'm like every minute that i'm not
producing something
that i'm wasting time
and i know that's probably like pretty
unhealthy but i don't really want to go
back from it because i've done so much
thinking like that so i don't really
want to go back to the thing where it's
like oh you know don't worry about it or
you know don't write stuff down because
it's not good enough
i just want to like produce as much as i
can produce
whatever it is
and and i want to make it as good as i
can make it but
i don't know so now i feel like every
time that i'm not doing something uh
whether it's like working out a book or
working on a video or something like
that if i'm not doing something like
that during the day that i'm like
wasting time
you know what i mean
i know that's bad probably because i'm
probably like getting i'm probably like
stressing myself out but
i don't know
i don't want to be in a different way
because i wouldn't get anything done
is that bad that's bad right yeah camp
guys saying i can't lose weight no
matter how much you exercise that's
because of your [ __ ] hormonal [ __ ]
situation i mean honestly like exercise
and stuff like that like yeah i exercise
like i do 20 miles a day but i also
eat
almost
nothing i hate it uh yeah but that's
that's a different situation though
you eat almost nothing because
you we were overeating for a while
well i kept telling that didn't happen
it doesn't didn't have to be that way
because i was kind of [ __ ] i i
overeat but i'm i take a lot of steroids
i can't overeat
uh i can't feed her that much though her
metabolism isn't running that fast
and i know we drink but you drink too
but that's a lot of
that's when you drink it's a lot of dead
calories that's what yeah if you haven't
that's what camp guys said hormones plus
alcohol yeah if you have the normal
metabolism of an older person you'll get
[ __ ] fat oh yeah okay
if you're on hormone replacement therapy
like i am and you're injecting
testosterone i have the [ __ ]
testosterone of two or three 18 year old
boys it doesn't matter if i drink or not
i'mma burn that [ __ ] up i [ __ ] i'm hot i
ready at heat all the time
[ __ ] my metabolism runs harder than a
teenager so i can eat anything i'm
losing weight
i can drink and lose weight i'm losing
fat gaining muscle but i work out too
jenny's also on hrt but the dosages on
women are [ __ ] tiny okay it's like a
drop a week of testosterone
20 milligrams
sometimes she does little maintenance
cycles of uh winstrol okay which is five
milligrams a day for a couple months
that also is a slimming effect
you got to watch it if you go too long
on that [ __ ] you can have [ __ ]
permanent changes but most changes in
women are [ __ ] temporary usually he's
trying to make me a gravely voice do you
know well i i already don't like like
the voice deepening yeah did i tell you
the other night the other night yeah i
think it's sexy it's some kim carne's
action you know
that's my it's my phone sex never
[ __ ] get caught it's just um i had a
dream the other night
that i grew a mustache
you're worried about it too much if
you're not you're not you're not good
enough i thought i thought i told you
but i guess i didn't yeah like a couple
nights ago i dreamed that i had a
mustache and i was trying to like shave
it off and everybody was like
looking at me and i'm like i'm trying to
shave off a mustache do you mind
yeah okay [ __ ] no there are younger
women out there that [ __ ] do not have
mustaches they have rough voices like
bakar nabiva who has a fantastic [ __ ]
figure she's like a little [ __ ]
female human leopard she's in her
[ __ ] late 20s
she takes a [ __ ] [ __ ] ton of that
stuff but she is still female okay
it takes a lot to do what you're talking
about
um but you know i know i don't i mean i
don't
okay
it's still honestly it still weirds me
out like hearing my voice yeah my voice
doesn't sound like well you weren't real
hormonal
uh to begin with in some of that stuff i
could uh
you had higher pretty high levels of
estrogen but that helps
retain body weight
see yeah no [ __ ] tell me about it so
we changed all that manually
let me explain something to people
when a male
passes andrenopods and when a female
passes menopause when you get to a
certain age
everything is off the table the hormones
are gone
if you want to go back to an earlier age
and when it comes to diet metabolism and
the way you look don't you dare bring my
[ __ ] period back don't you dare no i
won't do that it won't do that don't you
dare you want to do it because he said
earlier
i'm like
yeah absolutely you can do that no you
can do it it is good for you every now
and then bring that back absolutely not
absolutely not that was like the worst
i'm not i'm not if i'm before you know
you shouldn't want to do it you know
i have a very very high pain tolerance
always have my whole entire life
the only thing
that
[ __ ] me up
was that [ __ ] was my [ __ ] period
yeah i do not
want that back right absolutely not that
was like the [ __ ] worst i don't want
that the heel the the human
performance drug the natural human
performance drug is testosterone
men and women both produce it men
produce it at ten times the rate females
do
whatever a male takes a woman takes one
tenth of that okay
in general this is not medical advice
okay i'm not telling anybody to take
anything it's all a [ __ ] disclaimer
don't sue us i don't know you can't sue
us
[Laughter]
after you pass in drenopause and i hit
adrenopause man it [ __ ] hit me like a
ton of bricks man i could really tell a
difference
and a friend it affected you a lot more
than menopause affected me yeah and it's
because menopause for me and i'm not
like discounting like women that have
really bad menopause because i know some
women that did but mine was just kind of
like um i felt like i was going to die
mine felt just kind of like a shitty
inconvenience i felt i was like my
periods was way worse than this so i
feel like i have a couple hot flashes
not only did i feel like i was gonna die
i felt like i wanted to die
yeah i remember yeah i remember
i never felt that bad
boy it felt bad i never and it's
veterans are [ __ ] very susceptible so
are pro athletes
if you live if if a guy had a good
solid puberty and then
ends ends up living a life that's very
[ __ ] high energy
an exciting life
you're kind of addicted to higher levels
of endorphins and and and [ __ ]
androgens
when anadranopause hits you it's a huge
[ __ ]
decline
and you feel suicidal
that's what happened to elvis
and i think drugs had a lot to do with
elvis caused him to hit and elvis drug
use caused him to hit andrenopods early
he felt something was wrong so he just
started taking more and more drugs which
made it worse and he was getting older
so that's what happened to him
well the thing about it too is that that
generation also they didn't know
anything i can't well yeah one they
didn't know anything and two it's just
kind of like they put so much of their
identity i guess into
um their job and their kind of their
youth and all this other kind of stuff
so when they moved into a different
phase of life
they had a hard time they couldn't make
the idea dealing with it they couldn't
like adapt to it well they didn't know
the biology and the science behind
what's happening that's what i'm saying
um
in elvis time they had the ability to
[ __ ] give him tests had he he started
but they would have thought it was
unnatural
they're thinking of the time where like
hey your teeth fell fell out already
don't put false teeth in there hey
you're bald don't put on a wig
that's what i was that was the thinking
of the two that would be natural for me
to look like a [ __ ] old lady yeah
yeah yeah be natural so but no thanks
when the androgens are gone oh it's time
for you to die
no man [ __ ] put the androgens back in
there
you you can live to be a [ __ ] hundred
i got [ __ ] videos of dudes in their
[ __ ] 70s they look just like me
they mean they look like me look like
they're in their 50s
that chinese guy looks like me he's 73.
it's because his teeth fell out he put
teeth back in just it happened to be
testosterone okay
but you got to catch it before you get
too old 40s 50s around that time
before damage has been done because some
damage is irreversible
so
the [ __ ] hormonal starvation has a
lot to do with aging
genetics also plays a part
but genetics plays a part in how [ __ ]
bad how good your
how good your puberty was and how bad
your [ __ ] menopause or andrenopods
was too it's also genetic
when you lose your hormones inject
hormones if you can't afford them you're
[ __ ] but
you say i can't afford to do that but
you can afford to drink in a bar can't
you
well i don't know can they yes
well poor people are kind of [ __ ]
always
200 a month
that's a lot of money or you can go
underground [ __ ] and get it [ __ ]
underground for about a hundred dollars
a month i can't afford to that's bad but
the thing is is they got dudes that will
spend more at the bar than that hundred
dollars a month i don't but then if
you're really [ __ ] slick you know how
to use vpns
and [ __ ] cryptocurrency you can get
the [ __ ] to make what you need for about
even half that about 50 bucks a month
maybe 25.
and if you sell it to other people i
ain't going to give anything
yeah don't go there i don't want to give
anybody i'm going to go there
okay
but there are ways to [ __ ] make the
money that you need
or to trade for what you need
you know
but
uh no testosterone
you just have to know the dosage you
know how it works and i'm not just
making this up you can go on youtube and
you'll see women's clinics
that are encouraging women to go through
menopause to inject testosterone 20
milligrams a month that is the cookie
cutter
testosterone uh anthony or appropriate
recipient that also too that'll work
you'll feel a lot better and you won't
put on so much weight
because your metabolism will work be
working normally there are some other
things you can put in there to help
speed it up a little bit or to help you
and if you're working out it's even
[ __ ] better
if it's aerobics
you'll trim down and get kind of cut
if it's anaerobics in other words
lifting weights you'll get bigger more
massive but you have to have a higher
protein diet to do that
very simple
there's no secret to it these dudes like
to rock and jason stayed them and
[ __ ] all these dudes who got old and
look fantastic that's all [ __ ]
testosterone
and
anabolic steroids which are modified
testosterone that is also testosterone
just kind of a different
version of it
not quite the same but similar doing the
same thing
cheater testosterone
jeffy art says jenny would rock a
handlebar mustache yeah i'd be happy
happy to offer tips
in the dream
i grew a mustache it wasn't even in the
middle it was just like on the sides but
it was long
and i was just like holy [ __ ] i gotta
like shave the [ __ ] off and it's just
kind of like you know how um
when you're sleeping and you have to pee
in your sleep and you dream that you're
looking for a bathroom and then like you
can't find one that's acceptable
okay so i had that kind of a situation
where
i had the dream that i had this mustache
and i had to like shave it off but i
couldn't find a place like that was
private to shave it off because i didn't
want anybody seeing it
and you were kind of like you were in
the dream too and you were just kind of
like
i can't remember exactly wait nobody see
it nobody noticed
yeah that sounds like they're
interesting
i don't know if you did if you i think i
was trying to hide from you as well
because like i didn't really want you to
see the because i thought you'd get mad
at me because i had a mustache
so uh so i was trying to shave it off
like
being on the down low and i couldn't
like do it but
but it wasn't in the middle i remember
that like in the middle there wasn't but
it was just like really long like on the
sides i remember that like a fu manchu
mustache camp guy just research hormone
replacement therapy or hrt and there's
hrt clinics near you
uh you're probably in in general it's
about seven hundred dollars buy-in with
all your blood tests and everything like
that for that first month and then that
includes the hormones that you need then
after that it usually tends to be about
but somewhere between a hundred and two
hundred dollars a month after that and
there's they got other [ __ ] that they'll
give you like hcg or clomid and
things to keep you from shooting live
rounds if you know what i'm saying
there's a bunch of different ways that
you can do it um
you can go black market too there are a
lot of good black market sources of
stuff if you have vpns and [ __ ]
crypto
which will save you some money because
anybody can make testosterone that's an
easy
that's an easy [ __ ]
molecule to make
jeffy art says i also got creative adhd
yeah it's um
uh and said uh yeah you always wanted to
be perfect the first time out i think
that was a problem that it took me uh an
alarmingly long time to overcome yeah
because what one i want to correct
myself
there's no such thing as a testosterone
molecule a [ __ ] it's a testosterone
is a compound okay go ahead
anyway what i was saying was that
it took me a very long time to realize
because
i think this was a product
of me coming up in uh the gifted program
which actually was a good thing
but
because i
was taken out of regular school
and put into the gifted program in third
or fourth grade like back in the
late 70s early 80s
um everything was easy for me so i kind
of felt like everything from then on in
life was gonna be easy for me so like
when other things came along that were
difficult
um i didn't really know how to deal with
it so that was one thing i'm not like
[ __ ] on gifted programs back then
because i think they were good but i
think that that kind of like stymied me
a little bit
it took me an embarrassingly long time
to realize
that
one of the things that you could do
was you could write something and then
correct it later because one of the
things that i used to pride myself on
when i was uh actually all through my
teens and into uh college
was that i was very good at writing like
extemporaneous essays like i was really
good at like coming up with really well
written like stuff just off the you know
off the cuff
i didn't really have to like research
stuff or anything like i would just come
up with this really good stuff and
didn't have to correct anything
so i got used to doing that and so i
didn't really realize
that you could write something and then
later
come back and fix it
it took me a really long time to like
figure out that i could actually do that
everything had to be like really good
from the from the get-go
and i think that the crazy thing about
this is that if you guys have read
stephen king's on writing
which is actually one of the best if
you're a writer of any kind please read
that it's um it's an amazing [ __ ]
resource he does a lot of um there's a
lot of biographical stuff in there but
that's all like really helpful too
but it's very very
honestly that kind of like reading that
like blew my mind because i was just
kind of like holy [ __ ] i can actually
write something that's not that good and
then i can go back later and fix it
i know that's dumb but for a long time
that never occurred to me because i'd
never had to do that before
um everything just came naturally
okay so you know
i'm sorry go ahead
nevermind you're done okay sebastian
asked me how many milligrams of
testosterone should a man have a month i
train with weights and cardio up to now
i don't feel i have a problem with
okay that that first of all i'm not a
doctor
i can only tell you what other people
say
i can't get medical advice
not legally okay
a lot of it has to do with how old you
are
okay
and what it is that you want
there's a difference between replacement
and benefit
and then the straight up steroid cycle
okay
a man can take in general the cookie
cutter thing here in florida what
they'll do is give a man 200 milligrams
of testosterone scipione
a a week
okay
you can inject it as many times as you
want you can half that up to two
injections a week or you could you can
break it up into seven injections and do
it every day or one injection a week
it's got a long half-life on it so 200 a
week gives benefit and replacement
you start you move that up to 500.
okay well hold on let me explain that
200 if you're in your
30s or 40s
you can live on 200 a month
excuse me 200 a week
for the rest of your life
without a [ __ ] real risk of anything
other than being shut down but in terms
of you know
that's safe and you get something out of
it
when you start pushing 500 a week
you're that's a steroid cycle
if you're young you're not probably
wouldn't want to maintain that for very
long three three months out of time and
then rest and then three months three
months on three months off really good
if you're old
500 a week
you could run that
wouldn't affect your lifespan negatively
it might actually expand your lifespan
depending on when you started if you
started in your 50s
you could run a high level for a long
period of time and it might actually
you'd be like that chinese guy like a 73
and look like you're 50.
but you're they're doing this later in
life and they did not abuse these things
early in life
that that's the key everything is
you must study the men that went before
you
but in general here in florida they'll
give you 200 milligrams a week
and it's replacement and you'll see some
benefit
you can run on that forever
yeah
would i do that at 20 no you're too
young you got a long haul ahead of you
would i do that at 50 [ __ ] right hell
yes
i'd do it at 40. had i known i'd have
gone on in my late 30s
yeah
okay that's all i'm saying
oh and i'll do as much as 600. i've done
600 before
two or three months back to back it felt
[ __ ] great rebuild [ __ ] you feel
[ __ ] great but you got to back off of
it you really don't want to
run those levels for long periods of
time
that's what steroids are for steroids
there's less load on you which that's
it's more complicated all right um
all right let jenny talk
camp guys said i've got bad teeth yeah i
have about 18 crowns yeah holy crap so
they look good uh just got two crowns
mounted this week honestly um
genetically i was fairly lucky uh in the
sense that i got like pretty okay teeth
uh my siblings all didn't get that but i
never had to have braces
i have maybe i think i have one or two
fillings one of my teeth in the very
back did actually like break and fall
out like recently but
other than that like my teeth have
actually like held up pretty well i got
good teeth too i had to get all my all
my uh wisdom teeth removed
but i'm only missing one tooth one back
here oh no i never got my wisdom tooth
out oh i had mine no
they're still there
only missing one tooth and i broke it i
would bit down on it that's what i'm
saying like yeah mine uh it was a it was
a whole clove yoga whole clothes okay
cup i did on a cinnamon stick i was
giving it to a horse i [ __ ] put a
cinnamon stick bit i used to do it all
the time
buy the cinnamon stick in half and give
one for the [ __ ] horse and had to eat
it you know when i was feeding the
horses give the other half to another
horse i got a thick cinnamon stick one
day bit it and crack my [ __ ] tooth
yeah i did that too yeah like i said on
a whole clove yeah and it broke and like
for a long time i had like it's in the
very back but it's like i had that half
for a long time and then finally the
other half fell out but the other teeth
are like
pretty good i don't really have like i
haven't had problems with cavities or
anything like that so i got lucky in
that regard at least genetically that i
haven't really had like i said and i
didn't ever have to have braces or
anything like that and
i mean like i said my siblings were not
so lucky because other of them had to
have like other like a lot of stuff done
with their teeth but i never really did
not that i could afford to go to the
dentist anyway because i can't but you
know what i mean
don't no like no pain nothing like that
so it's uh it's all good it's all good
uh camp guy said i get good dental
insurance well it's a good thing i don't
have any insurance of any kind so
if i got sick i would be uh hosed
i'm not all that worried about it
because
i don't know like i said
i grew up like pretty poor
so
we didn't go to the doctor unless we
were absolutely dying i mean unless
something was really really wrong
i
mean
i mean okay for an example like other
night like
when was uh when did we watch
when did we do the review of jaws for
okay so the night that we watched jaws
for
we're watching that
i was having like a really really bad
uh
stomach problems like my stomach was
just like cramping like really really
bad like i don't even know what the [ __ ]
was going on with that
and tom kept saying do you want me to
take you to the emergency room do you
want i was like uh [ __ ] no because
i can't afford for you to take me to the
emergency room america so uh so yeah so
i didn't really want to take me to the
hospital because i can't pay for it and
i don't have any insurance i don't have
anything like that so
i don't know if that was just like um a
product of me growing up
in a family where
i mean
my parents like had insurance sometimes
but a lot of the times i felt bad about
costing them money so
unless like i said unless i was really
dying
i wouldn't i think the only time when i
was growing up
that they that they actually had to take
me to the hospital was when i fell
off some steps in my grandmother's house
and i thought i had broken my ankle
because when i fell it made a really
really loud popping sound now it didn't
hurt
but it made this really loud sound and i
was like oh that
that's not good that that sound was made
and i was just kind of like and then i
was gonna like just deal with it because
that's what i was used to doing i said
i'm just gonna wrap that up in an ace
bandage it'll be fine but then like the
next day
i was just a teenager
uh but then the next day
i was changing the ace bandage and my
mom
looked at my ankle and it was like this
big and it was purple and she was like
uh that's broken we're taking you to the
hospital so they took me to the hospital
now it wasn't broken
but they still put a cast on it
and
that was pretty much i think that was
the only time that i ever
that my parents ever had to take me to
the hospital and i didn't even actually
want to go to the hospital
they just made me go because they're
like we're pretty sure that's broken and
you need to deal with it but i will say
they put a cast on my leg even though it
wasn't broke they said this is a
terrible sprain but it's not horribly
broken but we should still put a cast on
it we live in a townhouse at the time
that had stairs and stuff and i was like
sliding down the stairs on my butt
and after about a week
of sliding down the stairs on my butt
and having to like walk around on cast
on like crutches and stuff i was like
[ __ ] this [ __ ] and i cut the cast off
myself with a knife because i was
tired of that [ __ ]
i was like whatever it'll heal or it
won't i'm really not worried about it at
this point
so i just cut the cast off my life
because that's how i do
you know it worked out okay it worked
out okay
happily it wasn't really broken so
but that's kind of how i do okay no stop
you are definitely looking for attention
that's why the whole
my whole aesthetic of that bookshelf
yeah because i have a bookshelf i got a
bookshelf right there there's a
bookshelf right here it's filled with
[ __ ] books all of the books
and well and that's not even all my
books actually all my books are on those
two really big book shows
this is the little bookshelf
but all the books that are on the bottom
i was like well those are just the old
ones that i got at like thrift stores
and stuff and if she tears up the spine
she goes over there does this with them
because she likes to tear the paper she
likes paper
so she'll go in there and like tear all
the papers so there's like all little
there's little paper
bits yeah where she tears it up
sometimes it's 8 28
yeah you're good
you guys says one of my first jobs was
modeling sculpting teeth on a dental lab
i was 14 years old
i mean
i don't remember last time i've been to
the dentist man
like i said i haven't had dental
insurance in like forever we're going to
shut it down in about a half hour thank
you yeah you want some d because yeah
i'm not gonna let the show go on to
three hours
okay i'm having a good time though
aren't you okay
okay it's just that you know obviously
we're gonna get something to eat gonna
cook and i don't want the show on to go
on for [ __ ] three and a half
something hours we'll do that three
months okay we'll let it hit three and
that's it so that's about a half hour
so
is there any topics that you guys wanted
to cover is there anything [ __ ] that
you guys wanted to talk about maybe uh
maybe about the haunting [ __ ] shows i
mean [ __ ] i'm enjoying the new
hauntings we did we gave you two
hauntings uh this week
i'm having a good time with those i'm
glad that we decided to yeah
bring that back well i'm having a good
time somebody suggested that and we
thought about like yeah we should bring
the haunting back it's like man that's a
good idea yeah well i kind of feel like
a lot of the people that are still like
with us nowadays yeah after all this
time after all these years um
kind of came on board
because of those
so
and those are like actually really fun
to do they're not like watching the
programs we like watching them it's not
like all and i'm not saying that like
doing the research it's not like
completely stressful some of these
movies are a chore to watch
it depends on what the movie is it
depends yeah um a lot of times and and
to be honest the michael crichton movie
was chore the other time i was like oh
well here's the thing
the matinees are easier because that's
usually something i just let you pick
that because it's like look if i pick it
and it's bad then he's gonna [ __ ] so
it's like i don't want to hear that
so but
when we do the movie retrospectives i
usually have to come up because the
patrons vote on those
so i usually have to come up i was like
okay well i have to come up with like
five
options
that
i feel like maybe
you would watch without complaining too
much
so
and that's getting harder and harder to
do like as
most of the good movies
have been
we've that we've already covered yeah
so i thought well oh coma it's like you
know uh 1978 it was michael creighton
you like other michael crichton movies
it's like yeah you know what i mean so
it was that now i liked it you didn't
love it now i did fall asleep a couple
times while we were watching it but i
was like super super tired yeah you know
just michael crine's hit and miss he's
always entertaining to a certain extent
but it's a retro entertaining
you know what i mean it's just like i
know what they were thinking i remember
what we were thinking back then you know
what i mean it's it's that kind of that
kind of an entertaining
but that's what i mean i like a lot of
70s movies for that reason
yeah
i remember the way we used to think yeah
so it's always like i said but
so it's always hard for me to pick
because i go through here's what i do
here's my process
when i go
because i have to do uh the poll and i
usually i usually pick like five movies
yeah for whatever the poll is for
patreon for the movie retrospective
so i'm like well this has to be
something that
tom will watch without complaining too
much
it has to be something that's available
on one of our streaming services for
free because i don't
necessarily want to pay for it so it
usually has to be on amazon prime or
shutter or
hbo max or hulu or something that we
already pay for so i usually like i will
scrub through all of those and look for
something
so then i try to like find five
and then i'll see like what everybody
voted for it's like
you know and i i do kind of feel like
and i got a comment the other day
that maybe we should do more
really old like classic like 50s and 60s
stuff
and i was kind of like maybe and
somebody said we should do more
universal monster movies
and i was just kind of like i wanted to
do [ __ ] fu manchu i kind of feel like
maybe we should because
we haven't really done a lot of
universal monster movies or even like a
lot of [ __ ] from the 50s and 60s that
actually i would really like to do
um and we haven't gotten around to this
so i kind of like that we did some 50s
sci-fi yeah you know that was cool
um
so maybe we should do more of that
because i kind of feel like we've got
more request requests for doing more of
that so far the best 50 sci-fi and i've
said this before was
was uh war of the worlds and then
and they were both kind of similar
movies although i wished them was in
color
i think i think them would have been
even better in color well they try and
and one of the things that was good is
about them
is that the dudes
and it's a dude driven movie it's the
cops and soldiers they got a hottie in
there and she's a scientist and her dad
that that's cool too well that kind of
happened a lot and that has a lot yeah
those movies of that era and then men
were impressed oh man not only is she
hot she's a scientist wow she actually
has brains and blueberries
yeah that's a great thing we can't deal
with it
too many things
it was a good message they portrayed her
as being and her and her dad treated her
as a professional and [ __ ] it was a very
good message i actually did like that
about it that her dad actually like
treated her as like a person which i was
like wow this is like kind of yeah
that's very progressive for like a movie
of that era well no well and then then
the he-man in the movie the he-man
that's what i'ma call them no they they
were they were positive they responded
positive like yeah she's hot and she's
smart yes indeed he's like oh i like
that so you know what i mean it's not
like that's nice so it was a good
message um
unless smart [ __ ] like that yeah like
i'm smiling we like we like that she's
smart we listen indeed
and then um
uh but what what what i really liked
about it being a veteran and everything
is that how good those dudes with guns
fighting them damn ass well because they
were all they were all surreal soldiers
they brought them on as actually yeah
yeah so they were doing some real close
combat with it with the giant ants and
the thompson submachine guns and [ __ ]
and uh they had real
military guys in there with the [ __ ]
vehicles [ __ ] firing rifle grenades
and [ __ ] [ __ ] off the m1
grands and carbines and thompson
submachine guns so it was authentic it
was the original version of aliens
and the colonial marines that's what
they're doing they're going down there
to go fight the aliens big [ __ ]
insectoid aliens it's very similar to
them
you you know they you know
they watched
that [ __ ] old what's his name who
directed that [ __ ] [ __ ] saw them and
[ __ ] goes yeah it's gonna be like
them
there was a lot of i mean that's an
iconic
period yes aliens may have been a copy
of them in a certain way
well aliens well alien and aliens took a
lot of uh cues from a lot of other
movies from that time not just them i
mean
that's kind of like a big one
period yeah but you know what i'm saying
james cameron i know james cameron
thought saw them because there's a lot
of [ __ ] from everybody saw that yeah it
was kind of like i kind of feel like
them yeah is the quintessential 50s big
bug module movie i mean you kind of if
you
if you're at all into like horror or
sci-fi or something like that you kind
of have to see that one it's like a
really
it's a building block yeah of a lot of
the stuff that came later on but the uh
them had had the best
small arms fighting close in fighting uh
uh blocking of of any movie the way
any 50s movie it looked like small arms
combat
it was shot like an action movie proto
action movie but that's where action
came from if you ask me that's the first
time i saw a [ __ ] realistically
depicted
close combat between
[ __ ] marine with a thompson sub
machine gun and a whole bunch of giant
engines and then and it was it was like
convincing i was like okay yeah that's
it
and you're only going to get that look
from that dude if he's already
comfortable with that weapon that was a
dude that was comfortable with weapons
doing that those were world war ii
veterans
well yeah that's why they brought those
dudes on for those yeah
i mean and if you look all the yeah all
the people that they yeah they were all
comfortable with weapons and good with
them so i i so and you buy it when you
see the movie
sebastian says the invaders with roy
then is i still want to see that because
if you guys don't know i just reviewed
it came out on thursday but i reviewed
the nor less tapes which many of you had
requested that was a 70s tv movie
and uh roy thinness was in that
and
uh yeah that was kind of his big thing
was the invaders and i still want to
like kind of get into that
but we'll see how that goes like uh
going forward
now somebody said
uh
this island earth was pretty good right
i remember i remember that i saw this
islander the [ __ ] brain [ __ ] on
yeah mystery science theater yeah i i
saw we gotta put write that one down
we're gonna see that i've never seen it
i've never seen the silent earth seen
pictures of the alien but i've never
seen the movie
mystery science theater
the movie yeah did this islander well we
can watch that now it was a cut version
we can watch that but i can still review
the movie based on it i mean it's a fun
movie yeah it's ridiculous but it's fun
ridiculous hugo says that them may be
colorized i wish it was there is a
colorized version is it
somebody colorized it was originally
going to be color
it was supposed to be and those ants
were all painted evidently and they
looked better when they were they did
they were like all purple and green
again yeah but
when they shot it they're like yeah i
don't look too good though yeah
there was that there was something else
that i needed to comment on
where was it
um jenny and tom you may like the
history of chingle hall
uh which is impressed in england my
first vigil case was steve mara oh there
okay
a really nice place with activity oh
okay i'm gonna write that down should
you work with steve
yeah yeah okay sebastian did sebastian
did okay
jingle haul all right write that down
yeah man yeah steve's a good guy man i
like steve i [ __ ] spent many hours
talking to steve we like steve
yeah he's a cool dude yeah i've written
a good pair of psychologists he
impressed books with him
super super knowledgeable
i haven't talked to him in a while
though i gotta [ __ ] touch bases with
steve see what he's up to is steve's
book selling it all lately
a little bit down there a little bit
okay i mean it's been a while it's been
it's been out for a while yeah so that's
once books have been out for a while
sometimes they start petering that's
what i mean all right uh camp guy said a
night of the hunter honestly i've been
wanting to do night of the hunter
for a really long time yeah that is a
classic from the 1950s i've seen it but
i don't think you've seen it
but
yeah it's really really good robert
mitchum yeah it's really good so we
don't owe steve any money then
no okay good make sure make sure you
know okay
he's getting paid yeah okay good michael
schaefer says jenny we've reviewed the
original king kong uh we haven't
uh reviewed it i've seen it many times
yeah it's a great movie but we can do it
like i said i kind of feel like maybe
everybody's done that though huh
yeah but we've gotten so many requests
to do like classic horror oh well we're
gonna do we should we're gonna do
[ __ ] kong we're also gonna do mighty
joe young
that's what i'm saying it's like
if we're gonna open up and i wanna do
like all the classic like
universal monster movies i'm gonna do
all the frankenstein movies i'm gonna do
kind of like i wanna do all that stuff
okay well then we'll do it what do we
can do i'm just saying we can do it
we can do [ __ ] bella lugosi movies
man there's like so many movies we gotta
do
they never really could
get
lugosi to be able to be dracula again i
think there's only two dracula movies in
there
well he didn't after that he had to be
another vampire that was like dracula
because i think it was copyrighted or
something wasn't it well
no i mean the thing about it was that
well no the problem arose when nosferatu
came out okay because they were trying
to make a dracula adaptation
and bram stoker's widow was like oh no
that's like that's some copyrighted
material so like i said they changed all
the names and stuff
now the first dracula movie
was actually based on the stage play
yeah which is not
the same similar but it's not yeah it's
it's based on stage play and not so much
on the novel so it's structured a little
bit differently
and then i kind of feel like people that
piss and moan about like sequels and
blah blah like nowadays
back in the 30s
they were doing all that [ __ ]
all that [ __ ] all of the like dracula
frankenstein wolf man all that kind of
stuff they had a million
sequels and offshoots and it's like you
know
[ __ ] the wolf man meets like abbott
and costello they had the nobody go to
like comedy and it's like they had all
that kind of stuff and they had like a
million sequels and all that kind of
stuff but most of them were like not
really that good but
i don't know i kind of feel like maybe
we should and i feel like too
we shouldn't just do the universal
monster movies i kind of feel like they
were not so much the 40s because the 40s
was a little bit lacks in horror
although cat people was good like val
luton was doing some good [ __ ] so in the
40s but in the 50s you had some good
like [ __ ] uh people have asked me to
do night of the demon which i think was
1957
if i'm not
mistaken so i've been wanting to do that
for a long time so we maybe should do
some like classic horror because i kind
of feel like right after schedule we'll
do it that's what i'm saying yeah i'll
watch all that i mean make up a schedule
i love that [ __ ] i love that [ __ ] put it
on a schedule i love that [ __ ] put it on
schedule jeffy alright says
manchu though that's in that yeah wait
which one the one that had the one that
had [ __ ] uh karloff in it
when it's hard oh okay
that's old yeah real old karloff because
that was a whole series and then like i
saw the ones that had uh christopher lee
no karloff who manchu i haven't seen it
in [ __ ] they said that it's a great
movie
but
for some reason hollywood doesn't want
to show it nowadays because you got
karloff he's doing i guess yellow face
but he's an actor but the thing about it
is that well i don't know if that's so
much that because i've seen who had that
back in the [ __ ] well and i've seen
other movies where he was doing that
that are more available
so it's not so much that i just i want
to see the original food manchu it's
supposed to be good
um
wait where did i see okay knight in
hunter king kong beast from twenty
thousand fathoms we should probably do
that one too because that's ray harry
yeah
and i love
love love love ray harryhausen i mean i
i first got into ray harryhausen when he
did all the [ __ ] nine
when i was nine because i saw clash of
the titans yeah the sinbad movies were
great we did them
we did yeah we did we did them all
didn't we
they had carolyn monroe in it we did a
couple of them at least
it was a gift to britain
carried them in a row
everybody loves countless man i was a
little kid [ __ ] you know [ __ ]
kimmy took me to see the [ __ ] i think
it was the third [ __ ] sinbad movie
and carol monroe was in it her [ __ ]
midriff and her [ __ ] boobs and [ __ ]
that girl was so [ __ ] i'm like
[ __ ] seven and i know a hot chick
when i see one i'm gonna go god i'd hit
that so everybody looks like i hit that
so bad [ __ ] yeah
i'd hit the [ __ ] out of that okay you
know i was [ __ ] crazy a little kid
not really crazy but saying you know i
was [ __ ] crazy about that ass
damn caroline munro
hugo said we also saw carol monroe in
the damn journey to the center of the
earth [ __ ] thing where they took it
like i said she was an athanasia yeah
and she was in that shitty one with uh
star crash she was a star crash yeah she
was on a bunch of [ __ ] which is a
terrible movie terrible i was a teenager
at that time i was still i still
recognized her entertaining for all that
i still recognized her by that time so i
was just like that hot ass carol monroe
yeah it's entertaining but i mean it's
terrible but it's entertaining yeah
hugo said would you consider a biography
show
of a classic actor like billy gossey or
boris karloff etcetera honestly we
probably should because i think didn't
we do a show about
christopher lee and peter cushing yeah
we did
pretty sure we did so probably maybe i
kind of feel like if we did chris marley
we should do carl from c and and
certainly they didn't get along
i don't know if it was as bad it was
[ __ ] playing as it was uh
you know portrayed i think it was played
no i think i think yeah but i get it
but if you hey if you like boris karloff
tomorrow
on my over on my scarce wand channel
i
have
for whatever reason
i decided to go on this journey where i
was gonna watch the entire series of
thriller which came out but it was 1960
and 1962.
boris carlive hosted it it was like an
uh an anthology program much like alfred
hitchcock presents yeah um
before i realized that it was actually
67 [ __ ] episodes
of what over two seasons 67 episodes 67
episodes of what
of thriller thriller so i was just kind
of like okay well i'm gonna break this
down into six episode chunks that's what
i'm gonna do
so tomorrow
uh i'm gonna put up a video where i
reviewed the first six episodes
of boris karloff
uh the show boris karl have hosted which
was called thriller which was on nbc
back in 1960. so
i'm going to put that up tomorrow so if
you're into bars karloff like look at it
like i said boris karloff is only like
the host of it so he's only like on
there for five seconds but you know what
i mean
uh i had been wanting to watch it for a
long time and i figured hey what better
time they have it on roku
so i watched it
at least first accepted so yeah so we
should probably do
a borah scott and honestly shutter if
you have shutter
they have a documentary
about
boris karloff i think it's called the
man behind the monster yeah and it's
really good like watch it i'm pretty
sure though based on everything that
i've been able to pick up over the years
between karloff and lugosi
that uh
that lugosi was jealous of karloff
lugosi was a [ __ ] he had player hate
crazy
uh i would probably prefer
lugosi when it comes to a event uh
a [ __ ] vampire type character but
karloff i've seen carlos in a lot of
[ __ ] i thought he was cool i thought
he's cool he's good
i like both of them to be fair but if i
if you put a gun in my head and i had to
pick
i'm going to pick carloff sorry
there's a rumors that karloff was kind
of dumb
i don't know if it's true but see i
don't understand honestly i don't know
who said that because i don't see that
yeah i don't see that i've seen some
other [ __ ] that he was in because boris
karloff that like i said that wasn't his
real name obviously but he was in a lot
of stuff and he never came across like
that to me so i don't really know like
where i think that was like some people
being
what was the trip about this
is that it wasn't known i don't think to
the general public but even back in
those days karloff is biracial karloff
yeah his dad was from india yeah and uh
he was part of the british empire but he
was a he was uh
he comes off as being very anglo and
[ __ ] but he was part indian you know
they're filming him in black and white
you know what i mean he had anglo
features but he was a little bit darker
colored and
he was you know [ __ ] uh indian
which you wouldn't think that with a
name like karloff you would think
russian or some [ __ ] but that's not his
real name no it's not just his real name
was william pratt yeah they did all that
[ __ ] back then they used stage names and
of course that's what i mean and and he
really got he really got famous playing
in his early roles just frankenstein's
monster well ethnic characters is kind
of like bit parts first yeah but he was
a good great actor and in [ __ ] people
liked him
you know and if i can he rose to [ __ ]
prominence greatness [ __ ] yeah well i
told you that was kind of why i wanted
to like on my scarcelon channel i was
just kind of like [ __ ] i've been
hearing about this thriller show like
forever because like look i'm into like
twilight zone and at our limits i'm it
alfred hitchcock presents i love all
that stuff
but
i heard stephen king
back in the day in dance macabre like
his old book from like 1980 or 1981 he
was always talking about thriller with
boris karloff i was like man i never saw
that because i was too young to see it
so i see roku has it
most of it and i was like man i'm gonna
watch that [ __ ] i'm gonna like put it on
the show
so i started watching it
and that shit's good now boris karloff
he's only like the host he's kind of
like the um
you know how on night gallery
um you had [ __ ] uh
what's his name like rod sterling like
just he was just introducing the [ __ ] it
was like that
but
i don't know man the [ __ ] was still good
i love horror anthologies and i love
boris karloff so i think that's gonna be
like i'm gonna watch that sorry i think
we did it already we covered the black
cat did we
pretty sure we did wait i don't know if
we did the black cat we did um
what was the one
no it was the one with uh we haven't
done the black cat we got to do the
black yet we haven't done the blackout
okay we make sure in the back out
because
if you ask me
karloff's best
work
was on a movie called the black cat it
was boris karloff bella lugosi oh wait
maybe we did back in the 30s
and karloff plays a character named
[ __ ] xiaomar
perils apparel zigg was his name
who was a [ __ ] military officer
who was a satanist
and sacrificed oh yeah we did we did he
was a military uh colonel i think is
what he was sacrificed his his
unit
on a certain plot of land
sacrificed them to the enemy as a
sacrifice to satan and they all got
wiped out so after the war he could come
back and buy that piece of land and he
made his [ __ ] satanic temple on it
which is a damn
a high tech for the 20s or 30s when like
30s [ __ ]
uh
mansion with [ __ ] sliding doors and
an intercom and everything and he's got
all these damn european
satanic elites showing up where they're
[ __ ] set doing [ __ ] sexual rights
and sacrifices
and it's just the most bizarre movie
from the 30s
he's got all his dead ex-wives and
girlfriends
yeah and their daughters
[ __ ] stored in glass coffins down
underneath the [ __ ] battles keep them
in you right yeah keep them in storage
right which is kind of like uh
necrophilia that he's keeping them as
sex dolls it's [ __ ]
for the 30s
badass and that's what star started all
this down well that was pre-haze code
that started the haze code from
understand it was movies like that they
were like no we can't have this
because they started to go like you're
implying that he's
[ __ ] corpses yeah it's called the
black cat
it's a classy
art deco style horror movie
my favorite thing about a lot of dark
elements my favorite thing about okay my
two favorite things about the movie one
the art design yeah i love
the set design on that yeah amazing the
costumes
uh and the costume is great you [ __ ]
i love some [ __ ] boris karloff yeah was
the biggest [ __ ] in that and i yeah
yeah i'm here for it
he was like like his smirking oh my god
i was so i was so in [ __ ] i love
boris carlos yeah and uh [ __ ] um
oh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
oh man [ __ ] um
bella bella plays a character that was
one of [ __ ] um bella's great in that
too yeah he's creating it too yeah he's
great he plays one of harry pelzick's
[ __ ] men who got captured during that
big sacrifice and he spent what was it
eight years or eight
nine years
yeah it's been a while but yeah he spent
it in a place called the cool gall which
is like a basically a concentration camp
and they finally let him out
and he goes back to track down his own
old [ __ ] commander and take vengeance
on him because he knew that he had
sacrificed the unit
to consecrate this ground in this
satanic i mean the whole like
interaction between the two of them and
he's looking for his wife so so good
it's so good and [ __ ] he was looking
for his wife his commander stole his
wife he finds out that the wife is dead
and that he's got possession of his
daughter he's keeping his daughter as a
[ __ ] sex slave
and she's walking around this beautiful
sheer robes and [ __ ] and it's all 30s
you can see she's nude underneath it
it's [ __ ] it's sexy you know
but he she's like his satanic bride
and uh [ __ ] the ghost he comes back
to kill his ex-commander in his [ __ ]
thing but they got to do it a
gentlemanly way they're playing [ __ ]
chess behind it and talking about it i
will kill you and all kind of like some
ingmar burgers yeah yeah yeah yeah it's
good it's real good it's real good
you can't just kill a [ __ ] out
of nowhere you have to talk it up and
[ __ ] make a challenge and explain why
you're doing this and you got to play
chess well you got to have like
parameters you can it's very like crass
yeah to just come in and just shoot a
[ __ ] in the face right and [ __ ]
you gotta have like some [ __ ] his
name was vita the uh his name the
character of [ __ ] bella's character's
name his name is vitus vitus veldegast
and [ __ ] he's got this bodyguard he
hired who's a who's this big ass uh
[ __ ] uh mongolian [ __ ] bodyguard
and he's so he's showing up with his
bodyguard to [ __ ] get his revenge but
it turns out when they show up to
[ __ ] pelzick's [ __ ] match for some
reason your servants become his servants
there's so there's some european
rules that go back yeah
i was not like real clear it's some kind
of honky motherland rule where i would
show up with your servants your servants
become the servants of the lord until
they [ __ ] the specific time
it's kind of complicated but it's just a
classy flick and some american
characters are watching this
and they're just simple it's simpletons
a pretty girl and a handsome guy and
they're tripping out over what these
europeans are doing
it's just you know what i mean we're
just americans why are these europeans
we're kind of stupid we're stupid we've
gone back to the honky motherland and
they're doing this we don't really
understand this they always got to do it
they represent you as the observer
i mean yeah
i advocate that though yeah i like that
whole like hey where the stupid people
that are like watching this stuff going
on yeah that kind of cracks me up yeah
but now i recommend the black cat
it's a fantastic tammy said if anybody's
gonna kill anybody be a gentleman about
it yeah exactly that's exactly what
they're doing i i like that i i i like
give a huge shout out to the black cat
that's the best boy boris carla bellagos
movie i've seen
it just like i said they were in a lot i
mean they were in a lot together and
they were before the haze codes so there
was there's no ratings they didn't know
anything about ratings i mean it's still
like pretty tame by today's statement
it was back then like yeah the
implications of the implications of what
they were talking about
yeah he [ __ ] mur he murdered
dude's wife
well and they imply
that he implied that he's having sex
with a dead body right and they imply
later on that like the guy he that he
gets skinned alive yeah we one of the
well they straight up tell you that's
what happened i mean they don't show it
but well like it was silhouette
silhouette just pulling his skin off
yeah yeah so it's a great flick but it
is in an older format the only thing i
didn't like about it is that the score
didn't quite match what was going on it
was like a star i actually remember the
score the score was like stock music
that they would play here and uh okay
but the story is tight
and the edits tight it's not that long
that's a great film yeah i think it's a
little bit over an hour well the thing
about it is like a lot of the movies
back then were
only like an hour and 15 minutes people
piss and moan like nowadays when a movie
is like an hour and a half but holy crap
like back then they were like
what 70 minutes yeah taps well because
back in the old days you'd go to the
theater
and you'd see a double feature and then
to be shorts and stuff like that so a
lot of the movies back then really like
an hour 15 minutes long
um
slash friend said one of these days one
of these wednesdays
you should do a show on john hughes
that might be actually that might be an
interesting show because
me
growing up in the 80s
i was really into john hughes movies i
understand that like a lot of his stuff
is like uh problematic nowadays but
i mean that was like a big part of our
uh
i don't know that was kind of a big part
of the zeitgeist when we were growing up
i feel like in the 80s pretty in pink
breakfast club
uh you know i mean i weird science i
kind of feel like those were like the
big ones but somebody's asking if i
carry a knife never carry a knife ever
if you carry anything you carry a gun
you carry legally
at least in the american system
carry legally carry a gun
um if not don't carry anything
honestly i don't carry anything because
i don't care enough i hardly ever leave
the house yes we don't care we don't
even i don't care anything
but if you do carry something carry a
gun carry it legally understand the laws
in your state understand what kind of
state you're in
some states really
on the books say they have self-defense
but they won't allow you to defend
yourself if anything goes down they're
gonna blame you
if you're in a state like that don't
care don't carry anything or move
you know
you got all these states you can move to
move to a state that fits your
personality
and if you can move that means you can
move out away from trouble spots
if you've got
if you have to carry a gun then you're
you're in the wrong place okay
i would not like to i would not like to
feel like i had to carry something
around all the time honestly i i mean
honest i didn't really don't feel the
need to leave the house much like i said
i work at home
uh when i go out i will go to dollar
general or
you know publix we go out to the club a
few times but that's about it
so
we don't really go anywhere where it
feels like we're in any particular
danger the reason why i say don't carry
a knife because if somebody attacks and
you pull a knife he now has the right to
pull a gun on you and shoot you under
most american state laws because you
pulled a knife on him
okay
so might as well just jump straight to
the gun
somebody attacks you you can pull a gun
and if they continue to attack you shoot
that person you defend yourself if you
feel your life's in danger if there are
no witnesses and everything you go ahead
and make a ditty mount there's no reason
to engage with the criminal justice
system here because the chances of you
getting a fair shake are [ __ ] minimal
okay
only go before the court if you're
arrested
if you understand my drift
okay
hugo says boris karloff tales of terror
1962 isn't an anthology
uh as far as i remember it is but it's
been a while since i've seen it i'm very
very into horror anthologies
not just like horror anthology movies
but i also like horror anthology tv
shows i was a big fan of alfred
hitchcock presents alfred hitchcock hour
twilight zone i loved all that [ __ ] like
i said i didn't see that stuff when it
first aired because i'm not that [ __ ]
old i'm old but i'm not that [ __ ] old
so but i was into that like as soon as i
saw it on uh you know
syndication i was like this is for me
it's like short story because i was
always really into like horror short
stories and stuff
so
when i saw that i was like yeah i like
this
so i've always
been really into horror anthologies i
think that was the reason that
you know i got the idea to do the
thriller thing
on scare salon i said this is it
this is one of my everests i guess
because like look i've seen twilight
zone i've seen outer limits i've seen
uh alfred hitchcock presents i've seen
alfred hitchcock hour i've seen all of
that stuff
but i kept hearing stephen king
i didn't keep hearing it but
you know in uh
dance macabre
he was talking about thriller and how
good it was and i was like [ __ ] like
boris karloff is hosting it and i love
boris karloff so i was like i never saw
that though i never saw that back in the
day it wasn't on and syndication and i
kind of feel like everyone forgot about
it so i was like i'm gonna do that i'm
gonna i'm gonna watch that whole [ __ ]
series
someday
so i decided to do it for the channel so
i was like okay i'm gonna take the
plunge and i'm gonna start doing it so i
like literally over the past three or
four days i was i watched like the first
like i said it's on roku i don't know if
like all two seasons are on there
but i found the first season at least is
on roku and i watched it for free daddy
dan uh was it danny rolling ghostbusters
says well a ballistic knife works the
same as a gun just saying and i said no
you're not you're tripping ballistic
knife works nothing like a gun you can
stab a person 70 times and they'll be
screaming the whole time and they'll
live afterwards
no stabbing somebody's nothing compared
to a gun
sorry
you shoot somebody with a nine
millimeter even 380 up close depending
on what kind of round it is and where
the chop placement was
you'll down that [ __ ] instantly
now with a knife you can stab somebody
[ __ ] repeatedly
you'll just complain about it
take a long long time to die
you can't kill me with a knife
i'm gonna punish you okay you come come
at me with a knife you've already lost
but you know i'm a train combat
don't tempt anyone yeah
don't tempt anybody no one's immortal
you're just me no no no no you're just
no you might kill me you might kill me
you're just me but i'll keep but you'll
end up dying before i will
you're just me everyone's me yeah it
takes a lot longer to die from blood
loss than blunt force trauma well that's
what i'm saying
and [ __ ] uh bullet wounds can we talk
about
just for a little bit here because this
is something that's always kind of
bothered me from horror movies in
particular
some [ __ ] in a horror movie gets
stabbed by some tiny little kitchen
knife yeah they're dead instantly and
they just like fall over dead i'm like
that's no not how that would happen that
probably wouldn't even kill you no
actually that probably you wouldn't even
be unconscious you'd be like hey
can you like take this out like yeah
this hurts and [ __ ] i got a friend that
was stabbed four times in a bar fight
many people have been stabbed many more
times than that and have survived and
been totally fine he got shot four times
during a bar fight in a in in in a time
frame of about
10 seconds
and it was all to the [ __ ] upper body
and he didn't he even go to the hospital
i mean you're fine yeah he didn't even
go to the hospital he says other clothes
wounds i'll be okay if you're not dead
in five minutes then you're not you're
not losing any damn blow yeah it was a
four inch foot four or five inch blade
he was sore as [ __ ]
sure it's not fun yeah but he didn't
even go to the [ __ ] you'll live then
you go to the cops behind it because
unless right unless they actually like
get a [ __ ] major artery then you're
in trouble but other than that
you're fine you're probably fine he
didn't go to cops but
he didn't go to the costa cause he was
in the bad behind it sure he could yeah
he started it
that's what i'm saying and i kind of
feel like i kind of wish
and i mean i feel like this has been
addressed in movies nowadays because
people are like really picky about
realism realism and stuff but i've seen
some stuff i'm a big fan of like star
from the
70s and whatnot and i think people back
then didn't realize that if you just
stabbed some [ __ ] like once in
the back or like in some random location
that you stabbed them and then like
they'd fall over and they were dead i'm
like that's uh not how that would happen
that person would still be alive and
they'd probably still be fine in the
state of mississippi
and during primitive
weapon season for hunting
it was required by state law that you
had to use poison pods if you're using a
bow you know recurve or
[ __ ] compound bow it doesn't matter
and it's because even with broad heads
which has a bunch of razor blades on
them there were too many deer that were
living you shoot the deer it goes right
through both ends of them bam
sounds like they hit with a damn
baseball bat and they run off never to
be found because they don't die you
didn't hit anything
and it went right through them he didn't
hit anything viable
so they put poison pot they they said
you had to have poison pods it was a
requirement in mississippi that way any
hit resulted in death
because you didn't want these [ __ ]
suffering deer some of them died but
died from infection later right okay
so
any hit was death
and you know when it came to bow it's
the same thing
if i were to [ __ ] hit a man with a
wreak with [ __ ] recurve or compound
bow even with broadheads chances are the
the arrow just goes right through you
and it's kind of it's kind of
it's kind of surgical you know i mean
depending on where it hits it closes
right back up i mean it would hurt yeah
i'm not saying that and it might get
infected might [ __ ] you over but
friend of ours are pretty [ __ ] sexy
would it kill you friend of mine maybe
not name aurora is this sexy chick
who has [ __ ]
got two kids
blonde
and she will have [ __ ] spikes shoved
through the meat of her back they're
about [ __ ] nine millimeter in
diameter and they'll suspend her from
the ceiling and she'll swing around all
night make money that way she'll also
have it stuck through her [ __ ] and
it's because it misses all those
arteries stabbing somebody's nothing
that's what i'm saying yeah
and these are [ __ ] bigger the spikes
that she's that she gets stuck through
are bigger in diameter or about the same
diameter as an arrow
shaft
i got it on video if you don't believe
me like i said it depends on where that
happens yeah now if i mean if you have a
really little knife
but you happen to hit at a really
crucial area
yeah then yeah the person will die and
they'll bleed out like pretty quick yeah
but most places that you stab in the
human body
um
you can live like quite a long time yep
like you will probably survive so that's
kind of why
and honestly the thing about it is that
not not just stabbing
but some people have been shot
in the uh in the midsection in the head
even
and they have also survived and been
completely fine
it just
depends on where the [ __ ]
that's that's the girl i'm talking about
depends on where it lands
that's the girl i'm talking about that's
jenny standing on the other side of her
okay i'm gonna show you another video
there's jenny right there
i was bright at frankenstein that night
all right
and that's her okay
let me show you another video of her
okay
this is a about an hour later
okay
she's got two spikes stuck through her
back and she's [ __ ] pulling on them
they're about as big around his arrow
shafts
see him
go through the meat and everything
like i said as long as you're not
penetrating any major organs yeah
then you're probably fine
that's the thing uh that's kind of like
what it what bothers me about a lot of
she's swinging from those things on her
back
and everybody watching
okay look at that
that's
through those [ __ ] spikes stuck
through her back
that's what i'm saying but in a lot of
movies
they will show somebody getting stabbed
one time in some non-crucial area and
then they fall over and they die
immediately and i'm like that's not
if you are going to stab somebody to
death
um
that's maybe a lot more than you want to
take on because it takes a lot yeah
unless you stab somebody right in the
[ __ ] heart or right in the [ __ ]
brain yeah
that takes a while it takes a while and
being shot's not quite the same it's a
lot more energy like i said well and a
lot of times it's a [ __ ] hollow point
bullet which is breaking apart and the
thing about being shot too is like a lot
of people have been shot and they have
also survived it depends on where where
it is what's the caliber uh where were
they trajectory where what it went
through
uh a lot of times you know anything near
the central nervous system or the head
heart major arteries lungs lungs can
fill up with blood
but if you're using things like [ __ ]
hollow point pistol bullets they'll kind
of break apart and they more internal
bleeding happens which take you down in
just a few seconds
you know the thing about some guys
some guys i got videos of it we sat
there shot 14 15 times by police with
[ __ ] nine millimeter
pistols
and they're still sitting there with a
knife in their hands struggling trying
to [ __ ] get at the cops like that you
know because it's kind of like assisted
suicide by police is what they're doing
i don't understand it or drugs i don't
know
but
but that's what i'm saying if you don't
get any vital organs right
then it's gonna take a while which
depending on what your end game is
uh you know that's going to be good for
you or bad for you i'm just saying that
no it's not going into fat fat would
tear right out it's going through the
muscle
she's suspended through muscle because
that shit'll go right through the top
her upper thigh muscles
yeah that's what i'm saying and
honestly most places that you hit in the
human body
is not gonna kill you yes
i mean it's not gonna be fun i'm not
saying that it's probably gonna hurt a
lot but it's probably not gonna kill you
so that's why i'm always kind of like
bothered by
stuff in
horror movies where somebody gets
i'm not like arguing people just get
like shot and they fall over that's fine
that's fine it's probably not what
really happened but yeah that's fine
but you get stabbed
with like a kitchen knife or some [ __ ]
like that like in the back and then you
fall over and you're dead yeah that's
not how that happens honestly like if
people get and people do get stabbed to
death like all the time
but
usually those people are stabbed
multiple times like usually people will
just stab and stab this happens you know
i write about your crime i know so it's
just kind of like i don't know so you
have to stab and stab stab
to kill that person
so
it's it's a messy situation it's a messy
situation that's what yeah
picture says definitely going through
fat the skin is what's keeping from uh
keeping it from ripping out yeah
tammy says or the old cowboy and indian
movies where they get shot with one
arrow and they fall over dead and i kind
of feel like they still do that
i don't know i don't i don't they don't
do that as much nowadays but i kind of
feel like they still do it
i don't know they still kind of do that
where it's just kind of like hey we
stabbed a person or we hit them with an
arrow or whatever the [ __ ] and then they
fell over and then they're like not
fighting with us anymore
but
yeah in reality that's not that's not
what would happen that's not what
happened
okay okay we actually went over
we are at three hours okay victoria says
it's definitely going through fat the
skin isn't that's right it's not though
because second if you look at um
her ex-husband jacob
he was a colombian performer that
[ __ ] had no fat he was maybe
[ __ ] five percent body fat it went
through his muscle and he was a pretty
well known
colombian performer i'll show him to you
but no it's not going through fat she
didn't have any fat
like i said there's a lot of places in
the human body
that are not i mean as long as you're
not penetrating any
uh
necessary organs
then yeah i mean i penetrate muscle all
the time and they give your judgment
you know it's just uh
it's about as big around as a [ __ ]
arrow shaft which is about
seven eight nine millimeters around that
that's not that big
okay
this is her ex-husband
all right and he does that [ __ ]
for a living on [ __ ] television all
the [ __ ] time and he doesn't have fat
that [ __ ] is almost just pure
muscle
okay that's jacob jacob we've had him
over to the house he's [ __ ] he's cool
dude he's been on a bunch of well he did
my uh he did that tattoo
trying to see
uh that must be his new girlfriend
he's a cool guy he's cool dude yeah i
like jacob he was uh a sniper in the u.s
in the colombian army
he's actually ex-military guy
his brother
his older brother was in the colombian
civil war and we got
accused of making a [ __ ] like a war
crime
his unit killed a couple hundred people
during a big [ __ ] shooting that they
had
no one was ever convicted it was just
okay so that's his new
girlfriend okay
some of it may be through like it does
look like that might be
through viscous but no i think that's
muscle that's going through muscle there
probably but look at it through the
thigh
i mean the thing about it though is that
if you did that to me
yeah i probably would not feel it yeah
that's what jacob looks like without his
makeup though
he's a really nice dude yeah ronai is
good he's a really nice dude
colombia is beautiful there's a lot of
really cool architecture there
he went back there yet yeah he's back
okay after after they broke up
he's gained a little bit of weight
but when we knew him and he was doing
all that he was at least [ __ ] five
pound ten pound i mean he was just skin
and bones but he's being suspended right
there
yeah he's i don't know i was like jacob
he was a he's a really nice dude he's
just a really nice person yeah he was
fun he was funny
he didn't quite
fit into america he couldn't find a
freaky enough job here
but in uh in a lot of well the weird
things
he can't
in a lot of ways like he came here like
we were kind of like yeah okay
and i thought he was like really nice
like i said he came to our house like
one night he did my tattoo
because he was a tattoo artist
and so he stayed at our house for
many
yeah how long did it take to do this i
just i don't know i just found another
video eight hours i saw another
photograph of that girl it does some of
it did look like it was going through
fat and skin but other parts of it was
[ __ ]
meat
some of that was meat
i think it probably depends on where the
where the connection points are going to
be and how much you weigh so it's going
to be like anything else they're going
to make strategic decisions i think
but yeah i mean obviously you can't but
there's a lot of parts of the human body
that you can
kind of like [ __ ] with and not not
really worry about it and don't worry
about it like too much native american
indians were [ __ ] suspended
themselves from this chest muscles
[ __ ] doing during [ __ ] spirit
walks
and [ __ ] going way back just sticking
[ __ ] huge bones through their sharp
and bone
so yeah it's going to probably be a
mixture of of meat and [ __ ]
like i said as long as you're not
penetrating any
vital organs
and you're not penetrating anything that
causes you to bleed to death yeah then
you're probably okay
don't do it i'm just saying that it's
probably okay it's probably
yeah it's about the old cowboy in any
movies they hit one arrow and shut up no
it never happened that's what i was
saying never happened that way
they get hit with an arrow and they try
to pull that arrow out and cause more
damage and leave the arrowhead in there
and they keep getting hit by several of
them
they would they'd be hit many times
before they [ __ ] died usually
yeah like a little arrow like in some
especially if it wasn't in a vital organ
caused problems though yeah it would be
painful
but get a bunch of them and it would
weaken them and then later on during the
attack [ __ ] there'd be an assault
phase where the indians [ __ ] ended up
into your
on your objective and then they beat you
to death with a war club or a [ __ ]
tomahawk
or the back end of a [ __ ] rifle there
was they used a mixture of stuff
sebastian says i would not like to be
stabbed in the heart though well i kind
of feel like nobody would be nobody
would want to be saving heart
yeah right yeah
it's almost time for us to shut it off
though
ah three and a half hours yes three and
a half hours i got we gotta make
something to eat right what you gonna
make what you gonna make um i'm gonna
see what's available
i know i got carnitas
oh that was good do you just want more
of that
sure okay
i'll come up with something
all right all right yeah
i'm pretty good pretty good yeah okay
all right so
we will be back
sunday evening
talking about a movie probably we don't
know which one
but thank you for dropping by this
evening you're not too drunk are you
um you're losing
what
it's like you're forgetting what you're
doing you slowed down or did i slow down
am i
probably okay
hey
it sounded like you lost track of what
you were doing
no i didn't okay but
now you're making me question myself i
gotta go i gotta go i'll see you guys
later man i'm gonna start making
something
okay he's gonna make some food
thank you this evening for dropping by
and hanging out with us this friday
evening
this is always fun i love friday
evenings i really do
uh so we will be back sunday
evening 6 p.m eastern standard time
we'll probably be talking about a movie
i don't know which one we haven't
watched it but
that'll be the next thing but thank you
for coming by and hanging out with us we
will see you again on sunday evening
and
thank you for coming by
for the side tracks
we will see you on sunday
and good